Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at PathwaysAlliance.ca
加拿大油砂开采产生了大量的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司携手合作，在通往净零排放的道路上大步迈进。他们投资于技术和创新，每桶石油的平均排放量已经减少了22%，与政府合作创造和保护就业岗位，并正在建设世界上最大的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在稳步推进，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 PathwaysAlliance.ca 了解我们的行动计划。
The crowd stood in awe with mouths agape. Their wide eyes focused upwards. A pitched squill filled the air followed by a cracking bang. Then another and another. It was Wednesday October 6, 1999. The night sky above the Spanish coastal town of Fuengirola was a fiery spectacle of colour. As the fireworks heralding the start of the Fuengirola Fair were ignited. Held in the centre of town, the annual festival draws in locals and tourists alike.
人群惊叹不已，目瞪口呆。他们睁大双眼，凝视着空中。一声尖锐的啸叫划破夜空，紧接着是一声脆响，然后是一声又一声。那是1999年10月6日，星期三。西班牙沿海小镇丰吉罗拉（Fuengirola）上空的夜空呈现出一场绚丽火热的视觉盛宴，宣告着丰吉罗拉集市的开幕烟花被点燃。这个一年一度的节日吸引了当地居民和游客，集市设在镇中心。
For a week-long party of food, drink and dance. The fairgrounds take over a large thoroughfare a short walk from the harbour. Easily accessible by a nearby train line. At ten days enter through one of three ornate gold and white arches before blending into a large crowd moving between attractions. Traditional music emanating from the festival echoes down the surrounding blocks as dozens of marquees offer visitors an array of foreign delicacies, live performances, souvenirs and exhibitions.
大家聚在一起，享受为期一周的美食、美酒和舞蹈盛宴。游乐场占据了距离港口步行不远的一条宽敞大道，附近有铁路线，交通十分便利。为期十天的集市设有三个华丽的金白相间拱门，游客从其中一个拱门进入，便汇入了穿梭于各个游乐设施之间的人潮。节日中播放的传统音乐回荡在周围的街区，数十个大棚为游客提供各种异国美食、现场表演、纪念品和展览。
Parades march down the street, providing a distraction for those waiting in line for the carnival rides. By Saturday October 9, 1999, the Fuengirola Fair was entering its third day and it was still as popular as ever. That night, a taxi driver dropped some passengers off in the Fuengirola area before heading south-west towards the coastal village of La Cala de Mijas. As he drove along a quiet, rural stretch of road between towns, he eyed his meter. It was exactly ten p.m. Suddenly, an SUV appeared up ahead.
游行队伍顺着街道前行，分散了那些在狂欢游乐设施前排队的人们的注意力。到1999年10月9日星期六，丰吉罗拉集市已经进入第三天，人气依然不减当年。那天晚上，一名出租车司机在丰吉罗拉地区放下几名乘客后，向西南方向驶去，前往沿海村庄拉卡拉德米哈斯（La Cala de Mijas）。当他沿着城镇之间一条安静的乡村公路行驶时，他看了一眼计价器。当时正好是晚上十点。突然，前方出现了一辆SUV。
It was parked on the side of the road facing the wrong direction. It was positioned in such a way that the taxi driver had to swerve to avoid colliding with it. Then he heard screaming, loud, terrified screaming. Fearing he was about to be carjacked, the taxi driver wound up his windows and sped up until the SUV disappeared in the darkness behind him. The next day Rocio Venenkov was looking forward to the Fuengirola Fair in October 1999. Juggling two jobs, one as an au pair and another as a waitress,
它停在路边，方向开反了。它的停放位置使得出租车司机不得不急转弯才能避免与其相撞。接着，他听到了一声尖叫，那是大声而惊恐的尖叫。出租车司机唯恐遭遇劫车，便摇上车窗加速行驶，直到那辆SUV消失在身后的夜色中。第二天，罗西奥·维宁科夫（Rocio Venenkov）正期待着1999年10月的丰吉罗拉集市。19岁的她身兼两职，一份是互惠生（au pair），另一份是女服务员。
the 19-year-old saw the event as an opportunity to unwind after a busy week. On the third day of the festivities, Rocio was lounging in the kitchen of her family home in La Cala de Mijas. She spoke with her mother and sister in forming them of her plans for the evening. First and foremost, she would visit her boyfriend, Antonio Jose Jurado. At around 10pm, she would return home, shower, and then head off to the Fuengirola Fair. At 5.30pm, Rocio left her home to walk the 500 metres to Antonio's house. Rocio's mother, Alicia, said she would await her return. When 10pm came and went with no sign of Rocio, it was clear her plans had been interrupted.
她将这次活动视为在忙碌一周后放松身心的大好机会。在庆祝活动的第三天，罗西奥正闲庭信步在她位于拉卡拉德米哈斯（La Cala de Mijas）的家中厨房里。她与母亲和妹妹交谈，告知了她晚上的计划。首先，她要去见她的男朋友安东尼奥·何塞·胡拉多（Antonio Jose Jurado）。大约晚上10点，她会回家洗个澡，然后再前往丰吉罗拉集市。下午5点30分，罗西奥离开家，步行500米前往安东尼奥的家。罗西奥的母亲阿莉西亚（Alicia）说，她会在家等女儿回来。当时间来到晚上10点却没有罗西奥的半点踪影时，很显然，她的计划被打乱了。
Had she chosen to bypass her stop-home and go straight to the fair with Antonio, Alicia couldn't be certain. Overcome with worry, she had to reassure herself that Rocio would reappear safe and sound in the morning. Upon waking the following morning, Alicia headed to Rocio's room, only to find her bed empty. She hadn't come home during the night at all. This was out of character for the sensible and considerate Rocio. Alicia sent Rocio's older sister, Rosa, to check in with Antonio. It seemed likely she would have spent the night there. Antonio answered the door.
阿莉西亚无法确信女儿是否临时改变主意，没有回家而是直接和安东尼奥去了集市。她被焦虑压得喘不过气来，只能不断安慰自己，罗西奥第二天早晨会安然无恙地出现。次日清晨醒来，阿莉西亚走向罗西奥的房间，却发现她的床是空的。她昨晚根本没有回家。这与平日里懂事体贴的罗西奥截然不同。阿莉西亚派罗西奥的大姐罗莎（Rosa）去安东尼奥那里查看情况。罗西奥很可能是在那里过夜了。安东尼奥打开了门。
He confirmed that Rocio had made it to his place early the following evening. A couple watched television for a few hours, then Rocio decided it was time to get ready for the fair. She arranged to meet Antonio at the fairgrounds later. She said her goodbyes to Antonio's mother, who expressed concern over Rocio's outfit. Rocio was only wearing a t-shirt, and she was concerned the teenager would get cold on the walk home. To placate her concerns, Rocio pulled on a grey sweater she was carrying. Her boyfriend's mother helped her button it up. Rocio thanked her, adding that she would see her soon.
他确认罗西奥在前一天傍晚很早就来到了他家。两人看了几个小时电视，然后罗西奥决定开始为集市做准备。她和安东尼奥约定稍后在游乐场汇合。她向安东尼奥的母亲道别，安东尼奥的母亲对罗西奥的穿着表示担忧。罗西奥只穿着一件T恤，老人家担心这个十几岁的女孩在走回家的路上会着凉。为了安抚老人的担忧，罗西奥套上了一件她随身携带的灰色毛衣。男友的母亲帮她扣好了扣子。罗西奥向她道谢，并说她很快就会回来。
A minute later, Antonio was escorted Rocio outside, and she began the short journey back home alone. It was 9.30pm. However, instead of meeting up with Rocio at the when-he-roll affair as they had planned, Antonio fell asleep and never made it. But he'd heard that Rocio had been spotted there, so she most likely enjoyed the night without him and headed to a friend's house. Rosa returned home and shared Antonio's explanation, but Alicia found it odd. She couldn't shake the feeling that something was amiss.
一分钟后，安东尼奥送罗西奥出门，她独自一人踏上了回家的小段路程。当时是晚上9点30分。然而，安东尼奥并没有像他们原计划的那样去丰吉罗拉集市与罗西奥汇合，而是睡着了，最终也没能去成。但他听说有人在集市上看到了罗西奥，所以她很可能是没有他陪伴也度过了一个愉快的夜晚，并去了朋友家。罗莎回到家转述了安东尼奥的解释，但阿莉西亚觉得这很蹊跷。她总有一种有什么不对劲的感觉，挥之不去。
As the day wore on with no word from Rocio, her worry increased. Her partner Juan tried to reassure Alicia that Rocio was of an age where nights out were expected, only for the young party-goer to show up later unscathed. He suggested they go for a walk to take her mind off things. Alicia and Juan headed in the direction of some picturesque ruins nearby. They stuck to the sidewalk alongside a semi-rural road surrounded by pine trees. Then, they turned and entered a clearing 300 metres from their home. It was there, amongst the grass and trees, where the couple spotted something.
随着时间一天天过去，依然没有罗西奥的半点消息，阿莉西亚的担忧与日俱增。她的伴侣胡安（Juan）试图安慰阿莉西亚，称罗西奥正值爱玩的年纪，偶尔晚归是意料之中的事，这个年轻的派对女孩过一会儿就会安然无恙地出现。他建议他们去散散步，好让阿莉西亚分散一下注意力。阿莉西亚和胡安朝着附近一些风景如画的废墟方向走去。他们沿着一条被松树环绕的半乡村道路旁的人行道前行。随后，他们拐弯进入距离家300米的一片开阔地。正是在那里，在草丛和树木之间，两人发现了异样。
Discarded on the ground were a pair of sneakers. They were Rocio's. Alongside them was a large pool of blood. Juan swiftly contacted the civil guard, the police counterparts outside Spain's metropolitan areas. Leading from the road were multiple specks of blood that trailed deeper into the adjoining clearing where the sneakers were located. A tissue caked with the dry blood was also discovered, as well as tire tracks that were likely caused by a compact car.
地上丢弃着一双运动鞋。那是罗西奥的鞋。鞋旁是一大滩血迹。胡安迅速联系了国民警卫队（西班牙大都市区以外的警察力量）。从路边一直延伸到鞋子所在的相邻开阔地深处，有多处星星点点的血迹。人们还发现了一张沾满干涸血迹的面巾纸，以及很可能是由紧凑型汽车碾压出的轮胎印。
Testing confirmed the blood belonged to Rocio Vanenkov. It appeared as though the 19-year-old was set upon between 9.30 and 10.00pm when she was walking home after visiting Antonio's house. This would mean that reports that she attended the Fuenjirol affair that night were likely incorrect. The bloody tissue was of particular interest to police. It suggested that whoever had harmed Rocio might have offered her the tissue to clean her injuries. This indicated a level of care and trust between both victim and perpetrator, as though they knew one another.
经检测，这些血迹属于罗西奥·瓦宁科夫（Rocio Vanenkov）。这位19岁的女孩似乎是在晚上9点30分到10点之间，在从安东尼奥家拜访完回家的路上遭到袭击的。这意味着有关她当晚出席了丰吉罗拉集市的传言很可能是错误的。那张沾血的面巾纸引起了警方特别的兴趣。这表明伤害罗西奥的人可能曾给她提供这张纸巾来清理伤口。这暗示着受害者和凶手之间存在一定程度的关怀与信任，仿佛他们彼此相识。
Further examination of the crime scene uncovered a cigarette butt, 4mm in length. Circled around the filter tip was the branding of cigarette company Royal Crown. Analysis revealed the cigarette had been smoked by an unknown male. October 12 marked the final day of the 1999 Fuenjirol affair. Rocio Vanenkov had been missing for three days. Her disappearance had become major news in her small hometown. La Cala de Mijas is, and was still very much then, a tranquil traditional village. Its few thousand residents lived private lives.
对犯罪现场的进一步检查发现了一个4毫米长的烟头。烟嘴周围印有皇家皇冠（Royal Crown）烟草公司的标志。分析表明，这支烟是由一名身份不明的男子抽过的。10月12日标志着1999年丰吉罗拉集市的最后一天。罗西奥·瓦宁科夫已经失踪三天了。她的失踪已成为她那个小家乡的头条大新闻。拉卡拉德米哈斯过去是、现在也依然是一个宁静的传统村庄。这里仅有的几千名居民过着私密的生活。
The local community was overseen by a parish who dealt with the issues troubling townsfolk. This internalised sense of protectiveness ensured everyone was tight-knit and looked out for one another. Outsiders were mostly tourists, expats or seasonal workers drawn to the area's warm climate and picturesque coastline. Rocio relied on this steady stream of visitors. Her au pair job was for one of the many British families who lived in the region. Her second job had her working behind the bar at a hotel popular with holiday makers. The money she earned brought her closer to her dream of studying to become a teacher. It was on this third day of Rocio's disappearance when a regional taxi driver came forward to police,
当地社区由一个教区负责管理，该教区负责处理困扰镇民的问题。这种内在的保护意识确保了每个人都紧密团结、守望相助。外来者大多是被该地区温暖的气候和风景如画的海岸线吸引来的游客、侨民或季节性工人。罗西奥的生活离不开这源源不断的游客。她的互惠生工作是为居住在该地区的许多英国家庭之一服务的。她的第二份工作是在一家受度假者欢迎的酒店里做酒吧服务员。她赚来的钱使她离成为一名教师的学习梦想更近了一步。正是在罗西奥失踪的第三天，当地的一名出租车司机向警方提供了一条线索，
realising he might have witnessed something significant. On the night Rocio failed to return home, he had been driving through the area where her shoes were later discovered. It was exactly 10pm when he spotted an SUV parked haphazardly on the side of the road. The taxi driver then heard screams, but fearing for his own safety, hastily left the area. At the time he passed the SUV, the taxi driver happened to see a man inside, sitting behind the wheel. He looked to be in his 20s or 30s and had short hair. This sighting facilitated a police sketch of the suspect, which was quickly distributed around town on flyers. Meanwhile, the wealthy English family who Rocio worked for came forward to offer a reward of 5 million paizettas,
他意识到自己可能目击了重要情况。在罗西奥未能回家当晚，他正开车经过后来发现她鞋子的那个地区。当时正好是晚上10点，他看到一辆SUV随意地停在路边。出租车司机随后听到了尖叫声，但由于担心自身安全，便匆忙离开了该地区。在经过这辆SUV时，出租车司机碰巧看到里面有一个人坐在方向盘后面。他看起来二十多岁或三十多岁，留着短发。这次目击促成了一幅嫌疑人警察素描的诞生，该素描很快就被印在传单上在全镇散发。与此同时，罗西奥曾为其工作的富有英国家庭站出来悬赏500万比塞塔，
the equivalent of more than 180,000 US dollars in today's currency, in exchange for useful information leading to her whereabouts. Hundreds of local residents volunteered to help search for Rocio. Strict schedules were organised, as nearby woods and towns were meticulously combed. On October 17, 8 days after Rocio had vanished, the biggest search yet was undertaken. The civil guard divided searches into groups of 6-8 cars and then sent them out in every direction. Nothing of value was uncovered. The last known person to have seen Rocio before she vanished was her boyfriend, Antonio Jose Horado. He would typically escort Rocio home after she paid him a visit, though she left his house alone on the key night.
相当于按今天的货币计算超过18万美元，以换取能指引其下落的有用线索。数百名当地居民自愿协助寻找罗西奥。他们组织了严格的时间表，对附近的树林和城镇进行了细致的搜寻。10月17日，在罗西奥失踪8天后，展开了迄今为止规模最大的搜寻行动。国民警卫队将搜寻力量分成每组6到8辆汽车的队伍，然后向四面八方派出。然而没有发现任何有价值的线索。罗西奥失踪前见到的最后一个人是她的男友安东尼奥·何塞·霍拉多（Antonio Jose Horado）。他通常会在罗西奥拜访后送她回家，但在那个关键的夜晚，她独自离开了他的家。
He also lived close to the clearing where her shoes were discovered. He would have been able to hear any screams emanating from the area via his window, which faced the same direction. Antonio maintained he fell asleep after Rocio had left his house, causing him to miss catching up with her at the Fuenhirola Fair later in the night. His mother vouched that he was asleep, though police didn't believe this to be a strong enough alibi. Investigators questioned Antonio on six different occasions. They also tapped his cell phone. But in all conversations, Antonio stayed true to his version of events. When it was determined that Antonio didn't have a driver's licence, it seemed unlikely that he was the man seen behind the wheel of the SUV at the crime scene.
他也住在发现她鞋子的开阔地附近。面向同一方向的窗户本应让他能够听到来自该地区的任何尖叫声。安东尼奥坚称他在罗西奥离开后就睡着了，导致他后来没能在丰吉罗拉集市上见到她。他的母亲作证说他当时确实睡着了，但警方认为这并不构成一个足够强有力的不在场证明。调查人员先后六次讯问了安东尼奥。他们还对他的手机进行了监听。但在所有的对话中，安东尼奥始终坚持他的版本。当查明安东尼奥没有驾照时，他似乎不太可能是犯罪现场那辆SUV方向盘后面看到的那个男人。
Police were willing to broaden their horizons and look for other possible suspects. On October 31, the Civil Guard informed Rocio's family that they were suspending all searches for the time being. But Rocio's family continued receiving support from local volunteers. Ever since she had vanished, a nightly tradition had been established. At 8.30pm each evening, searches would gather at the crime scene to share updates, possible developments and words of encouragement. Two days later, the owners of a tennis club in the resort city of Marbella stumbled across a disturbing site. Behind one of the courts and partially hidden by scrub was the badly decomposed body of a woman. She was naked, with her legs spread apart.
警方愿意拓宽视野，寻找其他可能的嫌疑人。10月31日，国民警卫队通知罗西奥的家属，他们将暂停目前的所有搜寻工作。但罗西奥的家人继续得到了当地志愿者的支持。自从她失踪以来，一项夜间传统便确立了下来。每天晚上8点30分，搜寻人员会聚集在犯罪现场，分享最新进展、可能的发展情况以及相互鼓励的话语。两天后，度假胜地马贝拉（Marbella）一家网球场的业主偶然发现了一个令人不安的场景。在一个网球场后面，被灌木丛半掩着，是一具严重腐烂的女性尸体。她赤身裸体，双腿分得大开。
Two industrial sized garbage bags were beside her, one of which had the number 8 drawn on it. They contained some jewellery and clothing, including a Nike brand t-shirt. The exact same as the one Rocio Vanenkov was wearing the night of her disappearance. A missing person flyer was also found next to the body. It featured a picture of Rocio and detailed the known circumstances of her disappearance. However, the condition of the body indicated that the victim had been deceased for at least six months. Rocio had only been missing for a little over three weeks. That night, Rocio's mother Alicia was attending a community meeting when she suddenly received a call to return home.
她身边有两个工业用垃圾袋，其中一个袋子上画着数字8。里面装有一些首饰和衣物，包括一件耐克（Nike）品牌的T恤。这与罗西奥·瓦宁科夫失踪当晚穿的那件一模一样。尸体旁还发现了一张寻人启事传单。上面印有罗西奥的照片，并详细说明了她失踪时已知的情况。然而，尸体的情况表明受害者已经死亡至少六个月了。而罗西奥失踪仅仅刚满三周多一点。那天晚上，罗西奥的母亲阿莉西亚正在参加一个社区会议，突然接到电话要求她回家。
As soon as she entered her house, she knew something was wrong. A police constable was standing in the living room, along with the town's parish priest. Alicia's daughter Rosa was seated at the table, holding her head in her hands as she cried. Alicia was informed of the body found at the Marbella tennis club. Police requested the family view the body in an effort to determine whether or not it was Rocio. Alicia couldn't face doing such a thing. Rosa opted to do so instead. Upon viewing the victim, Rosa noticed a familiar ring around her finger.
她刚一走进屋子，就知道出事了。起居室里站着一名警员和镇上的神父。阿莉西亚的女儿罗莎坐在桌旁，双手抱头痛哭。阿莉西亚被告知在马贝拉网球场发现了尸体。警方要求家属辨认尸体，以确定其是否为罗西奥。阿莉西亚无力面对这样的事。罗莎选择代劳。在看到受害者时，罗莎注意到她手指上戴着一枚熟悉的戒指。
It was one Rocio always wore. Rosa knew it was her sister. Marbella wasn't particularly close to La Cala de Míjez. It was around 20 kilometers west from where Rocio's shoes were found, in the opposite direction of Rocio's intended destination of Fuenhirola. Police speculated what might have caused the rapid decomposition. The killer could have burnt Rocio's body first or placed it in acid. It was also theorized that a rare type of wasp might have fed on her remains, expediting the process.
那是罗西奥常戴的一枚。罗莎知道那就是她的妹妹。马贝拉距离拉卡拉德米耶兹（La Cala de Míjez）并不是特别近。它大约在发现罗西奥鞋子的地方以西20公里处，与罗西奥原本的目的地丰吉罗拉方向相反。警方推测是什么原因导致了如此迅速的腐烂。凶手可能先焚烧了罗西奥的尸体或将其浸泡在酸液中。还有人推测，一种罕见的黄蜂可能吞食了她的遗体，从而加速了这一过程。
The civil guard was still under the impression that Rocio knew her killer or killers. The bloody tissue at the crime scene was too intimate of an object to overlook, and an autopsy confirmed their suspicions. Rocio had been stabbed nine times, with eight wounds in her lower back and one to her chest. It was a viciously brutal attack, one that seemed deeply personal. It was almost as though Rocio's killer had been motivated by revenge. Despite having been found naked, there was no evidence of sexual assault. Yet, the way her body was posed was suggestive and undignified.
国民警卫队仍然认为罗西奥认识她的凶手。犯罪现场那张沾血的面巾纸是一个过于私密的物品，不容忽视，而尸检结果证实了他们的猜想。罗西奥身中九刀，其中八处伤在下背部，一处在胸部。这是一次极其残忍的袭击，看起来带有深深的个人恩怨。几乎就像罗西奥的凶手是出于报复动机一样。尽管被发现时一丝不挂，但没有性侵的证据。然而，她尸体的摆放姿势却带有暗示性和不尊重的意味。
It was possible that the perpetrator intended to shame her. The missing person flyer left with Rocio's remains hinted that the killer was a member of her local community. Investigators pried into Rocio's inner circle of family, friends, acquaintances, and past flings. Each time they hit a dead end, they'd go back to the drawing board. Months passed with no major developments in the case. Then, on September 2, 2000, the Civil Guard paid Alicia a visit to share some big news. They were close to making an arrest for her daughter's murder. When Alicia asked who the suspect was, their answer astounded her.
凶手很可能是想羞辱她。留在罗西奥遗体旁的寻人启事传单暗示凶手是她当地社区的成员。调查人员深入调查了罗西奥的亲友圈、熟人圈以及过去的绯闻对象。每一次陷入僵局，他们都会重新回到起点。几个月过去了，案件没有取得重大进展。接着，在2000年9月2日，国民警卫队拜访了阿莉西亚，向她透露了一个重大消息：他们快要抓到她女儿谋杀案的凶手了。当阿莉西亚询问嫌疑人是谁时，他们的回答让她大吃一惊。
18 years earlier in 1981, Alicia was still married to Rocio's father, a Dutch resident named Guillermo van den Koff. Guillermo left his wife and three children when Rocio was two years old. Prior to this, Guillermo worked at a hotel to financially support his young family. As there, he crossed paths with a colleague named Dolores Vasquez. Guillermo introduced Dolores to his wife and the two women soon struck up a friendship. Alicia confided that she and Guillermo were in the process of separating. She was concerned about how she would manage raising three children as a single mother. At that time, the two women developed romantic feelings for one another.
18年前的1981年，阿莉西亚当时仍然与罗西奥的父亲——一位名叫吉列尔莫·范登科夫（Guillermo van den Koff）的荷兰居民保持着婚姻关系。在罗西奥两岁时，吉列尔莫抛弃了妻子和三个孩子。在此之前，吉列尔莫在一家酒店工作，以养活他年轻的家庭。正是在那里，他结识了一位名叫多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯（Dolores Vasquez）的同事。吉列尔莫把多洛雷斯介绍给了他的妻子，两个女人很快就结下了友谊。阿莉西亚吐露说，她和吉列尔莫正在办理分居手续。她很担心自己作为一个单身母亲该如何抚养三个孩子。在那段时间里，这两个女人对彼此产生了浪漫的情愫。
Eventually, they moved in together. They bought a house and shared the costs, although Dolores paid a larger portion and the contract was signed in her name. The couple lived together happily. Dolores helped Alicia raise her children. After almost 15 years, though, they decided to part ways. Their split was fairly amicable and they agreed to remain friends. Alicia and her children moved into another home nearby. Dolores stayed put and invited her mother, who was ill, to live with her.
最终，她们搬到了一起。她们买了一所房子并分摊费用，尽管多洛雷斯支付了较大比例，且合同是以她的名义签的。两人生活得很幸福。多洛雷斯帮阿莉西亚抚养孩子。然而，将近15年后，她们决定分道扬镳。她们的分手相当友好，并同意继续做朋友。阿莉西亚和孩子们搬到了附近的另一所房子里。多洛雷斯留在了原地，并邀请她生病的母亲来和她一起住。
When Dolores had learnt of Rocio's disappearance, she'd reached out to Alicia and offered support. She participated in searches, visited the family often, and even suggested that they hire a private investigator when it seemed the Civil Guard was making little progress. Unbeknownst to Dolores, the Civil Guard were making progress. They had spotlighted her almost from the get-go. During the first week after Rocio's disappearance, investigators noticed a strange car repeatedly driving through the clearing where Rocio's blood was found. Two men got out and approached the officers, seemingly trying to find out how the gathering of evidence was advancing. Extremely suspicious of the men, officers jotted down the car's license plate number.
当多洛雷斯得知罗西奥失踪的消息时，她联系了阿莉西亚并表示支持。她参与了搜寻，经常去看望这家人，甚至在国民警卫队似乎进展甚微时建议他们雇佣私家侦探。多洛雷斯并不知道，国民警卫队其实取得了进展。他们几乎从一开始就把目光锁定在她身上。在罗西奥失踪后的第一周，调查人员注意到一辆奇怪的汽车多次驶过发现罗西奥血迹的那片开阔地。两名男子下车走近警员，似乎想打听证据收集的进展情况。警员对这两名男子产生了极大的怀疑，于是记下了该车的车牌号。
When they looked it up later, they found the vehicle was registered to Dolores Vazquez. Investigators asked around about Dolores and were intrigued to learn she had close personal ties to Rocio's family. They called her into the station for an interview. When asked whether she'd lent her car to two men, Dolores firmly denied doing so. After the interview concluded, one of the officers escorted Dolores back to her car. As he glanced into the vehicle, he spotted a beige cap inside. One of the men seen at the clearing had been wearing the exact same hat. The investigators' suspicions grew stronger.
他们后来一查，发现这辆车登记在多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯名下。调查人员四处打听多洛雷斯的情况，惊讶地发现她与罗西奥的家人有着密切的私人联系。他们传唤她到警察局接受问话。当被问及是否将车借给两名男子时，多洛雷斯坚决予以否认。问话结束后，其中一名警官护送多洛雷斯回到她的车边。当他往车内瞥了一眼时，他发现里面有一顶米色帽子。在开阔地被目击到的两名男子之一，当时戴的就是这顶帽子。调查人员的怀疑进一步加深了。
They were certain Dolores was lying about the car, and if she was lying about a relatively minor matter, what else might she be lying about? It turned out that the hotel where Dolores was currently employed was located very close to the tennis club where Rocio's body had been dumped. After 11 months, investigators decided it was time to share their theory with Rocio's mother. The thought that her former partner could be responsible for her daughter's death shocked and horrified Alicia. She struggled to believe that Dolores, who had essentially been a second mother to Rocio, could do such a thing. That night, Alicia picked up the telephone and dialed Dolores's number. As soon as Dolores answered, Alicia blurted out, Did you do it? Did you kill Rocio?
他们确信多洛雷斯在汽车的事上撒了谎，既然她在这么一件相对较小的事情上撒谎，那她还会在什么事情上撒谎呢？事实证明，多洛雷斯当时受雇的酒店距离抛弃罗西奥尸体的网球场非常近。11个月后，调查人员决定是时候与罗西奥的母亲分享他们的理论了。前伴侣可能是女儿死因元凶的想法让阿莉西亚感到震惊和恐惧。她很难相信，对罗西奥来说犹如第二个母亲的多洛雷斯会做出这种事。那天晚上，阿莉西亚拿起电话拨通了多洛雷斯的号码。多洛雷斯刚一接听，阿莉西亚就脫口而出：“是你干的吗？是你杀了罗西奥吗？”
There was a pause. Then, Dolores replied in a quiet voice, How can you ask me that? This answer unsettled Alicia. Surely, if Dolores were innocent of such a heinous crime, she would loudly protest against the accusation and say it was ridiculous. But Dolores didn't scream. She didn't get angry. She just sounded heard. The pair didn't speak again. Three days later, on September 5, the media officially named Dolores Vasquez as a suspect in Rocio Vanenkov's murder.
电话那头停顿了一下。接着，多洛雷斯用平静的声音回答说：“你怎么能问我这种问题？”这个回答让阿莉西亚感到不安。当然了，如果多洛雷斯没有犯下如此滔天罪行，她一定会大声抗议这一指控并称其荒谬。但多洛雷斯没有尖叫，没有生气。她听起来只是感到受伤。两人再也没有通过话。三天后的9月5日，媒体正式将多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯列为罗西奥·万enkov谋杀案的嫌疑人。
The headline was accompanied by an image of Dolores doing her grocery shopping. A photographer snapped the candid photo while the unsuspecting Dolores was going about her day. Two days later, Dolores was interrupted at home by civil guard officers wielding handcuffs. She didn't make a fuss as they placed her under arrest. She was marched outside where crowds of television crews and angered onlookers were waiting. Dolores only spoke to ask a neighbour to please watch over her mother. She was bombarded with obscenities by the crowd who called her murderer. Some even tried to run her down and hit her.
头条新闻旁配有一张多洛雷斯正在买菜的照片。一名摄影师在毫无防备的多洛雷斯过着日常生活时抓拍了这张照片。两天后，国民警卫队警官手持手铐打断了多洛雷斯在家的生活。当他们给她戴上手铐时，她没有大吵大闹。她被押出屋外，外面聚集了成群的电视摄像机和愤怒的旁观者。多洛雷斯开口说话，仅仅是请求邻居帮忙照看她的母亲。她遭到人群的恶言相向，人们叫她杀人犯。甚至有人试图开车撞她。
During questioning, Dolores insisted that she was innocent. She claimed that she'd been home on the day of Rocio's disappearance. Because she was a caregiver to her sick mother, she didn't leave her alone often. Additionally, her niece had come to town that day for a night out with friends and left her two-year-old daughter in Dolores's care. Dolores explained that she wouldn't leave a toddler on her own. Detectives didn't believe her. On September 9, Dolores Vasquez was presented to a judge and ordered to stand trial.
在审讯期间，多洛雷斯坚称自己是无辜的。她声称在罗西奥失踪的那天她一直待在家。因为她是生病母亲的看护人，她不常把母亲独自留下。此外，她的侄女那天来到镇上与朋友过夜，并将她两岁的女儿托付给多洛雷斯照顾。多洛雷斯解释说，她不可能把一个幼儿独自留下。侦探们并不相信她的话。9月9日，多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯被带到法官面前并被下令接受审判。
The civil guard had compiled a document detailing 20 items of evidence against her. As she had a sister living in the UK, she was deemed a flight risk and transferred to jail to await her trial. With her former partner having been charged for the murder of her daughter, Alicia kept reflecting on their relationship. The more she thought about it, the more she realized there had been warning signs for some time. Things had been wonderful when her kids were small. Dolores had been like another parent to Alicia's three children
国民警卫队整理了一份详细列举了对她不利的20项证据的文件。由于她有一个姐姐住在英国，她被认为有潜逃风险，因此被转移到监狱等待审判。随着前伴侣因谋杀她女儿而被起诉，阿莉西亚不断反思她们之间的关系。她越想越觉得，其实很长一段时间以来都有一些警告信号。在孩子们小的时候，一切都非常美好。多洛雷斯对阿莉西亚的三个孩子来说就像另一个家长，
and had known Rocio since she was a toddler. Dolores assisted with their education and provided financial support. But cracks began to appear after about ten years, around the same time that Rocio hit puberty. The way Alicia remembered it, Dolores became controlling as the children got older. She always wanted them to do chores around the home and demanded they achieve good grades. After Rocio received poor marks at school one year, Dolores grounded her for an entire summer.
而且在罗西奥还是个幼儿时就认识她了。多洛雷斯协助他们的教育并提供经济支持。但大约十年后，裂痕开始出现，大约正值罗西奥进入青春期的时候。在阿莉西亚的记忆中，随着孩子们长大，多洛雷斯变得具有控制欲。她总是希望孩子们做家务，并要求他们取得好成绩。有一年罗西奥在学校成绩不佳后，多洛雷斯罚她整个夏天不准出门。
As time went on, the hostility between Dolores and Rocio grew. One day, Rocio came to her mother to complain about it and ended up screaming. One day, Dolores is going to kill me and you won't do a single thing about it. These words troubled Alicia and she'd ended the relationship soon after. She explained to Dolores that they could still be friends, but they couldn't be together anymore. Dolores was heartbroken. She didn't take the news well. The pair stayed in touch, but after a few years, Alicia began dating her current partner, Juan. When Dolores heard about the relationship, she showed up at Alicia's doorstep asking intrusive questions.
随着时间的推移，多洛雷斯和罗西奥之间的敌意越来越深。有一天，罗西奥来向母亲抱怨此事，最后甚至尖叫起来。有一天，多洛雷斯会杀了我的，而你什么都不会做。这些话让阿莉西亚感到不安，不久后她便结束了这段关系。她向多洛雷斯解释说，她们还可以做朋友，但不能再在一起了。多洛雷斯心碎了。她无法接受这个消息。两人保持着联系，但几年后，阿莉西亚开始与现任伴侣胡安约会。当多洛雷斯听说这段恋情时，她出现在阿莉西亚的门前，提出了许多刺探性的问题。
Alicia humoured her for a while, but the questions began to make her uncomfortable. She asked Dolores to stop. Dolores did, though she made one final remark. She told Alicia that one day she'd hit her where it hurt the most. Then Alicia would be left crying, quote, blood tears. Alicia had never forgotten this statement. When she called Dolores after learning she was suspected of Rocio's murder, she couldn't resist saying,
阿莉西亚应付了她一会儿，但这些问题开始让她感到不舒服。她要求多洛雷斯停下来。多洛雷斯照做了，但她留下了最后一句话。她告诉阿莉西亚，总有一天她会给阿莉西亚最痛的一击。到那时，阿莉西亚将“流着血泪”哭泣。阿莉西亚从未忘记这句话。当她得知多洛雷斯涉嫌谋杀罗西奥而打电话给她时，她忍不住说道：
you've hit me where it hurt the most. Dolores replied, that is true. As far as Alicia was concerned, Dolores had just confessed to the crime. While Dolores awaited trial, investigators continued building their case against her. In an early search of her home, industrial-style garbage bags were found that matched the ones found with Rocio's body. Apparently, Dolores used them when she went running as a way to increase sweat production. Officers got their hopes up when they found a tracksuit with fabric that appeared to match some fibers recovered from Rocio's body. But this turned out to be a false lead when analysis revealed the two were unrelated.
你给了我最痛的一击。多洛雷斯回答说：“这倒是真的。”在阿莉西亚看来，多洛雷斯刚刚承认了罪行。在多洛雷斯等待审判期间，调查人员继续收集针对她的证据。在早期对她家的搜查中，人们发现了工业风格的垃圾袋，这与在罗西奥尸体旁发现的袋子相吻合。显然，多洛雷斯在跑步时使用它们来增加排汗。当警官们发现一件材质似乎与罗西奥尸体上提取的一些纤维相匹配的运动服时，他们燃起了希望。但经分析发现两者毫无关系后，这条线索被证实是错误的。
Although investigators weren't having much luck finding physical evidence, the circumstantial evidence was stacking up. Acquaintances and colleagues described Dolores as cold, detached, and insensitive. Her ex-housekeeper said Dolores had a violent temper. Once, she'd smashed a cup of tea just because it was cold. Others felt that she'd behaved in an overly emotional way during searches for Rocio and at her funeral. She'd cried almost too hard in a way that felt performative. She also seemed protective of Rocio's family to the point of possessiveness. Dolores had claimed that on the night of Saturday, October 9, she'd been at home watching over her mother and grandniece.
尽管调查人员在寻找物证方面运气不佳，但间接证据却在不断堆积。熟人和同事将多洛雷斯形容为冷漠、疏离且麻木不仁。她的前管家说多洛雷斯脾气暴躁。有一次，她仅仅因为茶凉了就砸碎了一个茶杯。其他人则觉得她在搜寻罗西奥和葬礼期间表现得过于情绪化。她哭得几乎太厉害了，给人一种表演作秀的感觉。她对罗西奥家人的保护也似乎到了占有欲过强的地步。多洛雷斯曾声称，在10月9日星期六的晚上，她一直待在家照顾母亲和重侄女。
But a neighbour said Dolores's niece and grandniece had arrived in town the following day, Sunday, October 10. A waitress who worked at a bar situated right outside Dolores's house reported that at around 11.30pm on October 9, Dolores had come in dressed in running gear. She'd bought some tobacco and when the waitress asked what Dolores was up to, she said she'd just gone on a run to clear her mind. The next day, Dolores attended a wedding. She asked a friend to drive her, explaining that her car was being repaired. When the friend arrived to collect her, she told Dolores that she looked beautiful. Dolores said she was surprised. She'd had a restless night and hadn't slept at all.
但一位邻居说，多洛雷斯的侄女和重侄女是在第二天也就是10月10日星期日才到达镇上的。一名在多洛雷斯家门外的一家酒吧工作的女服务员报告说，在10月9日晚上11点30分左右，多洛雷斯穿着跑步装备走了进来。她买了一些烟草，当女服务员问多洛雷斯在干什么时，她说她刚刚去跑步清醒一下头脑。第二天，多洛雷斯参加了一个婚礼。她请一个朋友开车送她，解释说她的车正在修理。当朋友来接她时，她告诉多洛雷斯她看起来很美。多洛雷斯说她很惊讶，因为她度过了一个不安稳的夜晚，根本没睡。
Several days later, the waitress who'd served Dolores on the night of October 9 saw smoke rising from Dolores's chimney. When another employee at the bar followed up with Dolores and asked what she was burning, she claimed she'd simply been clearing the chimney out. But the waitress felt the amount of smoke had been far too excessive to just be some soot. Several weeks later, on November 2, Dolores arrived home looking troubled. She was met by her housekeeper. When the housekeeper asked Dolores what was wrong, Dolores pulled out one of Rocio's missing person flyers. Then she picked up a knife, held it against the flyer and stabbed it repeatedly in the middle of Rocio's photograph. This incident had taken place on the same day that Rocio's body was found.
几天后，曾在10月9日晚上服务过多洛雷斯的女服务员看到多洛雷斯的烟囱冒烟。当酒吧的另一名员工跟进询问多洛雷斯在烧什么时，她声称自己只是在清理烟囱。但女服务员觉得烟雾量实在太大，不可能仅仅是一些煤烟。几周后的11月2日，多洛雷斯回到家，神情困扰。管家迎了上去。当管家问多洛雷斯怎么了时，多洛雷斯掏出了一张罗西奥的寻人启事传单。接着她拿起一把刀，贴在传单上，在罗西奥照片的正中央反复捅刺。这一事件恰好发生在发现罗西奥尸体的同一天。
Dolores had apparently mimed how the 19-year-old was murdered before her cause of death was publicly known. In the months leading up to Rocio's murder, Dolores had been a frequent caller to psychic phone lines. Yet after Rocio went missing, these calls had virtually ceased. A psychic who Dolores had visited five months before Rocio was murdered was tracked down and interviewed. She claimed Dolores had confessed she was heartbroken. She wanted her former partner back, but the partner's child was standing in the way. Supposedly, Dolores had told the psychic that her ex would cry, blood tears. Investigators put together a theory as to how Rocio had been killed.
显然，在死因被公之于众之前，多洛雷斯就已经模拟了这位19岁女孩是如何被谋杀的。在罗西奥被谋杀前的几个月里，多洛雷斯频繁拨打心理咨询热线电话。然而在罗西奥失踪后，这些电话几乎完全停止了。警方追踪并采访了一位多洛雷斯在罗西奥被谋杀前五个月曾拜访过的灵媒。她声称多洛雷斯曾坦白自己心碎了。她想要回她的前伴侣，但伴侣的孩子挡了路。据说，多洛雷斯曾告诉这位灵媒，她的前任会“流着血泪”哭泣。调查人员拼凑出了罗西奥遇害经过的理论。
On October 9, Dolores went for a run between 9.40 and 10.00 pm. She carried a pocket knife as a safety precaution. In the middle of her exercise, she crossed paths with Rocio, who was walking home to prepare for her night out. The pair talked, and the bad blood between them caused an argument to break out. Dolores punched Rocio in the face, then gave her a tissue to clean her wounds. While Rocio was distracted by her injury, Dolores took out her pocket knife and stabbed her in the chest. Rocio turned and ran away, leaving spots of blood on the road. After running a short distance, she collapsed.
10月9日晚上9点40分到10点之间，多洛雷斯出去跑步。她随身携带一把折叠刀作为安全防范。在她锻炼的中途，她遇到了正步行回家准备出门的罗西奥。两人交谈起来，她们之间积怨爆发了争吵。多洛雷斯打了罗西奥的脸，然后给她一张面巾纸清理伤口。当罗西奥被伤口分散注意力时，多洛雷斯掏出折叠刀刺向她的胸口。罗西奥转身逃跑，在路上留下了点点血迹。跑了一小段距离后，她倒下了。
Dolores struck again, this time stabbing her repeatedly in the back. When Rocio was dead, Dolores realized she needed to dispose of the body. She went home and returned to the scene a few hours later with her car. She placed Rocio's body in the boot and kept it there for several days. That was why she'd needed a friend to drive her to the wedding on Sunday, and why she hadn't gotten any sleep that night. A few days later, she burned Rocio's body in an effort to disguise the remains, then dumped her at the tennis court in Marbella, along with the garbage bags full of Rocio's clothing. It was possible she'd enlisted the help of some young men.
多洛雷斯再次下手，这一次是在她背部疯狂捅刺。罗西奥死后，多洛雷斯意识到她必须处理掉尸体。她先回了家，几个小时后开着车回到了现场。她把罗西奥的尸体放进后备箱并在里面藏了好几天。这就是为什么她星期日需要朋友开车送她去婚礼，以及为什么她那天晚上没有睡觉的原因。几天后，她焚烧了罗西奥的尸体以图毁尸灭迹，然后将她连同装满罗西奥衣物的垃圾袋一起抛弃在马贝拉的网球场。她有可能寻求了一些年轻男子的协助。
This would explain why there was a cigarette butt with male DNA at the crime scene, and why two men were seen driving around in her car. In the lead-up to the murder trial, news anchors and television hosts debated whether or not Dolores was guilty, with most deciding that her anti-social-sounding personality pointed towards guilt. Members of the public were inclined to agree. The case was one of the biggest in the country. Everyone had heard of Rocio Vanenkov and Dolores Vasquez. In September 2001, Dolores's trial began.
这就解释了为什么犯罪现场会有一个带有男性DNA的烟头，以及为什么会看到两个男人开着她的车到处转悠。在谋杀案审判前夕，新闻主播和电视主持人纷纷辩论多洛雷斯是否有罪，大多数人认为她反社会倾向的性格指向了有罪。公众也倾向于认同这一观点。这起案件是全国最大案件之一。所有人都听说过罗西奥·万enkov和多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯。2001年9月，多洛雷斯的审判开始了。
Hundreds of reporters and curious onlookers piled into the courtroom to observe the proceedings. Dolores was pleading not guilty. Alicia testified for the prosecution, telling the jury that she was in no doubt that her ex had murdered her daughter. Various character witnesses were paraded through the court, sharing stories of Dolores's domineering and calculating personality. An undercover officer from the Civil Guard had even befriended Dolores while she was in custody, and provided a report describing Dolores as incredibly cold. The jury of five men and four women deliberated for 30 hours before returning with a verdict. Guilty.
数百名记者和好奇的旁观者挤满法庭旁听诉讼程序。多洛雷斯坚称自己无罪。阿莉西亚作为控方证人出庭作证，告诉陪审团她毫不怀疑是前任谋杀了她的女儿。各种品格证人在法庭上轮流作证，讲述了多洛雷斯专横和算计的性格故事。国民警卫队的一名便衣警官甚至在多洛雷斯被羁押期间与她交好，并提供了一份报告，形容多洛雷斯冷酷至极。由五名男性和四名女性组成的陪审团经过30小时的审议，最终做出了裁决：有罪。
The courtroom erupted in loud applause and cheering. Alicia and her family hugged one another tightly. As Dolores broke down in tears, photographers and news crews closed in, trying to get a close-up. Her attorney draped a coat over her to hide her distress. Dolores Vasquez was sentenced to 15 years and one day in prison. She was also ordered to pay 30 million pesetas in compensation to Rocio's family, close to US$220,000 in today's money. When asked if she had anything to say in response, Dolores quietly muttered. Continue searching, because the killer is still out there.
法庭内爆发出一阵雷鸣般的掌声和欢呼声。阿莉西亚和她的家人紧紧相拥。当多洛雷斯崩溃大哭时，摄影师和新闻团队蜂拥而上，试图拍摄特写镜头。她的律师用外套盖住她，以掩盖她的痛苦。多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯被判处15年零1天监禁。她还被责令向罗西奥的家属支付3000万比塞塔的赔偿金，按今天的货币计算接近22万美元。当被问及是否有话要说时，多洛雷斯轻声咕哝着：“继续找吧，因为真凶还在外面。”
Sonja Carabentas grew up in Switzerland. When she turned 15, she moved with her parents to the inland Spanish town of Coyin. On Wednesday, August 13, 2003, Coyin was abuzz with activity. The annual Feria de Agosto, August Fair, had arrived in town. Streets were adorned with paper lanterns and floral displays. The sounds of flamenco and coplar music radiated from the fairgrounds, where crowds had gathered to take in the many festivities and performances on display. Among them was the now 17-year-old Sonja Carabentas.
松嘉·卡拉本塔斯（Sonja Carabentas）在瑞士长大。在她15岁时，她随父母搬到了西班牙内陆小镇科因（Coyin）。2003年8月13日，星期三，科因到处是一片热闹景象。一年一度的八月集市（Feria de Agosto）降临小镇。街道上装饰着纸灯笼和花卉展览。弗拉门戈和科普拉（coplar）音乐的声音从游乐场传出，人们聚集在那里欣赏各种庆祝活动和表演。其中就包括当时17岁的松嘉·卡拉本塔斯。
She celebrated with her friends long into the night. Afterwards, Sonja headed home on foot, accompanied by a friend. At around 5am, the pair were within 200 metres of Sonja's home. As her friend lived on the opposite side of town, they said their goodbyes and continued on separately. The next morning, Sonja's mother opened her front door. On the pavement outside was a pool of blood. More blood was splattered across the hood of a car parked nearby. Sonja's mother edged closer.
她和朋友们一起庆祝到深夜。之后，松嘉在一位朋友的陪伴下步行回家。凌晨5点左右，两人距离松嘉的家已经不到200米了。由于她的朋友住在镇子的另一头，两人便道别并各自继续前行。第二天清晨，松嘉的母亲打开了前门。外面的路面上一滩血迹。更多血迹溅在附近停着的一辆汽车的引擎盖上。松嘉的母亲走近了一些。
She then discovered something even more upsetting. Scattered on the ground was Sonja's mobile phone, her purse, and a shoe she'd been wearing the night before, now covered in blood. The Civil Guard found more things lying nearby. A piece of a broken car tail light and a lock of hair that was the same dark brown as Sonja's. There were other notable objects. A cigarette butt and a tissue covered in dried blood. More than 700 of Koyin's residents volunteered to help search for Sonja Carabentas.
接着，她发现了更让人揪心的一物。地上散落着松嘉的手机、钱包和她前一晚穿的一只鞋，鞋上沾满了血。国民警卫队在附近找到了更多东西：一截断裂的汽车尾灯碎片和一缕与松嘉同款深棕色的头发。还有其他引人注目的物品：一个烟头和一张沾满干涸血迹的面巾纸。科因有700多名居民自愿协助搜寻松嘉·卡拉本塔斯。
Divided into groups of ten, they covered much of Koyin and the surrounding area. On August 18, one group scouring a highway on the outskirts of town stumbled across a pair of jeans by the roadside. They resembled the pair that Sonja had been wearing on the night she went missing. When he heard about the jeans, Sonja's father travelled to the area with a clairvoyant. The clairvoyant led Sonja's father away from the road and into a dense, wooded area. She said she felt like Sonja was nearby, but they found no sign of her. The following morning, four volunteers took a sniffer dog to where the jeans had been found. It led the group into the same heavily wooded area that Sonja's father had visited the day before.
他们十人一组，搜遍了科因以及周边的大部分地区。8月18日，其中一组人在镇郊的一条公路旁搜寻时，偶然在路边发现了一条牛仔裤。这条裤子与索尼娅失踪当晚穿的那条很像。听到找到牛仔裤的消息后，索尼娅的父亲带着一名灵媒来到了现场。灵媒将索尼娅的父亲从公路引向了一片树木茂密的区域。她说她感觉到索尼娅就在附近，但他们没有找到任何关于索尼娅的踪迹。第二天早上，四名志愿者带着一只警犬来到了发现牛仔裤的地方。警犬把搜寻队伍带到了索尼娅的父亲前一天去过的那片树木繁茂的区域。
The dog was eager to get close to some trees so its owner loosened its leash. After racing forward a few meters, the dog stopped. Nearby, partially buried beneath a pile of rocks, was the half-naked, badly decomposed body of Sonja Carabentas. Sonja's lower half was exposed and her t-shirt had been pushed up. Her bra was torn. Though the attacker peered sexually motivated, there was no evidence that she had been raped. Her face had been struck repeatedly, her jaw almost broken. Then she'd been strangled to death.
警犬急切地想要靠近几棵树，于是它的主人松开了牵引绳。在向前冲出几米后，警犬停了下来。在附近一堆乱石下半掩埋着索尼娅·卡拉班塔斯半裸且严重腐烂的尸体。索尼娅的下半身暴露在外，T恤被推到了上面。她的胸罩被撕破了。尽管袭击者的行为看起来带有性侵动机，但没有证据表明她曾遭到强暴。她的面部遭到多次重击，下巴几乎被打碎。随后她被勒死。
Sonja put up a fight. Skin belonging to her attacker was found under her fingernails. Analysis revealed it belonged to a male. His DNA was also found on the cigarette butt discarded outside Sonja's home. Surprisingly, the DNA matched to a third item, another cigarette. This one was found three years prior, in a grassy clearing 25 kilometres away in La Cala de Mijas. The Royal Crown brand cigarette butt found at the Rocio-Vanenkoff crime scene was almost overlooked at the time. Luckily, it was spotted by an officer during a thorough sweep of the area.
索尼娅进行了反抗。在她的指甲缝里发现了属于袭击者的皮肤。经分析，皮肤属于一名男性。在索尼娅家门外丢弃的烟头上也发现了他的DNA。出人意料的是，这个DNA与第三个物证——另一支烟相吻合。这支烟是三年前在25公里外马拉加省拉卡拉德米哈斯的一片草地空地上被发现的。在罗西奥-瓦年科夫案发现场发现的皇冠牌烟头当时险些被忽略。幸运的是，它在对该地区进行彻底清查时被一名警官发现了。
Testing revealed it had been inhaled by a man. The Vanenkoff and Karabantas cases shared a number of similarities. The victims were only two years apart in age and roughly similar heights. Rocio was half Dutch while Sonja was Swiss. Both had long brown hair that fell below their shoulders, worn in almost identical styles. And both had disappeared while walking home after attending or planning to attend a local fair. Though they had been killed in different ways, they had been beaten. There was no evidence to prove either teen had been sexually assaulted, but both were found naked or partially naked.
检测显示这支烟曾被一名男子吸过。瓦年科夫案和卡拉班塔斯案有许多相似之处。两名受害者的年龄仅相差两岁，身高也大致相仿。罗西奥是半个荷兰人，而索尼娅是瑞士人。两人都留着垂过肩膀的深褐色长发，发型几乎一模一样。而且两人都是在参加或计划参加当地集市后步行回家时失踪的。尽管两人遇害的方式不同，但她们都遭到过殴打。没有证据证明两名少女受到过性侵犯，但两人被发现时都是赤身裸体或半裸。
In 2001, Dolores Vazquez was found guilty of Rocio's murder. The motive was believed to be personal. However, Dolores had no connection to Sonja Karabantas. And at the time of Sonja's murder in 2003, Dolores was at home under police surveillance. After Dolores was incarcerated, she began to spiral. She'd always maintained her innocence, but public opinion had cemented her as a killer. Once known as a quiet and calm person who was kind in a reserved way, it didn't take long for perceptions of Dolores to change following her arrest.
2001年，多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯被判谋杀罗西奥的罪名成立。人们认为行凶动机是私人恩怨。然而，多洛雷斯与索尼娅·卡拉班塔斯没有任何联系。并且在2003年索尼娅遇害时，多洛雷斯正处于警方的居家监视之下。多洛雷斯入狱后，她的精神状态开始急剧恶化。她一直坚称自己是无辜的，但公众舆论已经认定她就是凶手。多洛雷斯过去以文静沉着、为人温和且略带内向著称，但在她被捕后，人们对她的看法很快就发生了转变。
Soon, the narrative reversed. She was now described as cruel with a violent temper. Although investigators had done their utmost to coax a confession from Dolores, she never cracked. She was patient and compliant, even when questioned for two days straight. During her first night in detention, officers switched the lights on and off at random intervals. Dolores had an intense fear of the dark and was certain they knew about this. She felt they were trying to break her. At one point, an officer told Dolores,
很快，舆论风向彻底逆转。她现在被形容为一个冷酷无情、脾气暴躁的人。尽管调查人员已经竭尽全力诱使多洛雷斯招供，但她始终没有崩溃。她表现得很有耐心且十分配合，甚至在连续两天的审讯中也是如此。在她被关押的第一天晚上，警官们随机开关灯。多洛雷斯对黑暗有着强烈的恐惧，并且确信他们知道这一点。她觉得他们是在试图击垮她。有一名警官甚至对多洛雷斯说，
we're going to make you famous and not even your lawyer will believe you. Following her guilty verdict, Dolores questioned her own memories. During a visit with her attorney, she asked, if I did it and can't remember it. Dolores's lawyer firmly believed she was innocent and encouraged her to maintain her faith while he worked on an appeal. Others also believed Dolores had been wrongly convicted. A group of attorneys and researchers who'd followed the case published a blog advocating for her innocence. Chief amongst their arguments was the fact that Dolores had been convicted without a shred of physical evidence.
我们要让你出名，到时候连你的律师都不会相信你。在被判有罪后，多洛雷斯开始怀疑起自己的记忆。在与律师会面时，她问：“如果是我干的，而我又记不起来了呢？”多洛雷斯的律师坚信她是无辜的，并鼓励她保持信念，而他则着手准备上诉。其他人也相信多洛雷斯是被冤枉的。一群关注此案的律师和研究人员发表了一篇博客，为她的清白发声。他们最有力的论据之一是，多洛雷斯在没有任何实质性物证的情况下被定罪。
They also pointed out a number of inconsistencies in the prosecution's case. From the beginning, Dolores had insisted that she'd been at home babysitting her niece's daughter on the night of Saturday, October 9. A neighbour claimed she'd seen Dolores' niece arrive the following day. However, the niece in question backed up Dolores' alibi. She said she'd arrived on Saturday night at 10pm, around the time Rocio was attacked. During the trial, the prosecution presented Dolores' telephone records to emphasise how often she called clairvoyance, which they found suspicious. But these same records were advantageous to the defence. As Dolores' attorney showed the court, Dolores had made two separate calls to friends on the night of Saturday, October 9.
他们还指出了控方案件中的许多矛盾之处。从一开始，多洛雷斯就坚称自己在10月9日星期六的晚上一直在家里帮侄女带孩子。一位邻居声称她看到多洛雷斯的侄女在第二天到达。然而，涉事的侄女证实了多洛雷斯的不在场证明。她说自己是在周六晚上10点到达的，这正是罗西奥遇袭的时间左右。在庭审期间，控方出示了多洛雷斯的通话记录，以此强调她给灵媒打电话的频率有多高，他们觉得这很可疑。但这些通话记录反倒对辩方有利。正如多洛雷斯的律师向法庭展示的那样，多洛雷斯在10月9日星期六晚上曾分别给朋友打过两个电话。
One took place between 10.34 and 11.10pm. The other was at 11.17pm. If her niece arrived at 10pm and Dolores was on the phone from 10.34pm, she had barely any time to run four kilometres, encounter Rocio, murder her, then run back home again. And if the murder occurred before Dolores' niece arrived, there was an even smaller window for her to run from the crime scene to her home. Furthermore, tyre tracks found at the crime scene didn't match Dolores' car. They had been left by an older model Ford Fiesta. Dolores drove a newer Toyota Celica. To overcome this obvious discrepancy, the prosecution suggested Dolores stole a car to transport Rocio's body.
其中一个电话是在晚上10点34分到11点10分之间打的。另一个是在晚上11点17分。如果她的侄女在晚上10点到达，而多洛雷斯从10点34分开始一直在打电话，她几乎没有时间跑四公里去遇到罗西奥、谋杀她，然后又跑回家。如果谋杀发生在多洛雷斯的侄女到达之前，那么她从案发现场跑回家的空档时间就更短了。此外，在案发现场发现的轮胎印与多洛雷斯的车不符。这些轮胎印是一辆旧款福特嘉年华留下的。而多洛雷斯开的是一辆较新的丰田赛利卡。为了掩盖这个明显的矛盾，控方暗示多洛雷斯偷了一辆车来运送罗西奥的尸体。
With every post shared by Dolores' supporters, the credibility of the case was further diminished. Journalists and more attorneys began to question the guilty narrative. Finally, on February 2, 2002, Andalucía's Superior Court of Justice agreed to annul Dolores Vasquez's conviction and order a new trial. On February 8, Dolores was released from prison under the proviso that she surrender her passport and submit to any and all searches of her home by the Civil Guard. Rocio Venenkov's family were very upset by this. They felt that by releasing Dolores, the courts had placed them in grave danger. What if Dolores decided to seek revenge against them? They requested that she be placed back in custody, but their request was denied. Several months later, on July 1, Rocio's family received another shock when a new report was published. Titled the Crespecio dossier, it had been compiled by Officer Crespecio, the first policeman who'd attended the Venenkov crime scene.
随着多洛雷斯支持者发布的每一篇帖子，案件的可信度进一步降低。记者和更多的律师开始对有罪论调提出质疑。最终，在2002年2月2日，安达卢西亚高等法院同意撤销对多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯的有罪判决并下令重审。2月8日，多洛雷斯获释出狱，条件是她必须上交护照，并接受国民警卫队对其住所的任何及所有搜查。罗西奥·维宁科夫的家属对此感到非常不安。他们觉得，法院释放多洛雷斯的举动将他们置于极度危险的境地。如果多洛雷斯决定找他们报复怎么办？他们请求将她重新收监，但请求被拒绝了。几个月后的7月1日，罗西奥的家人迎来了一份新报告的发布，再次受到了惊吓。这份名为《克雷斯佩西奥档案》的文件是由克雷斯佩西奥警官汇编的，他是第一位到达维宁科夫案发现场的警察。
He wasn't a member of the Civil Guard. He was a forensic police officer for the city of Marbella, which is in the same region as La Cala de Mijas. As the case wasn't in his jurisdiction, he hadn't formally investigated it, but he'd always maintained an interest. After investigating Rocio's murder independently, Officer Crespecio concluded that Rocio's uncle had murdered her with assistance from her cousin. An irregular fingerprint had been recovered from one of the garbage bags near Rocio's body, and her uncle was known to have a V-shaped scar on one finger. Rocio's cousin was a young man who resembled the SUV driver spotted by the taxi driver on the night of the crime. The house he lived in was number 8. The garbage bag found near Rocio's body had that number drawn on it. There was little evidence to back up Officer Crespecio's controversial theory. It was subsequently dismissed due to lack of proper protocol and scientific approach. Some members of law enforcement believed Officer Crespecio had released his findings because he wanted 15 minutes of fame.
他不是国民警卫队成员。他是马贝拉市的法医警察，马贝拉与拉卡拉德米哈斯属于同一地区。由于该案不属于他的管辖范围，他没有进行正式调查，但他一直对此保持着兴趣。在独立调查了罗西奥的谋杀案后，克雷斯佩西奥警官得出结论：罗西奥的叔叔在表哥的协助下谋杀了她。在罗西奥尸体附近的其中一个垃圾袋上提取到一枚不规则的指纹，而众所周知，罗西奥叔叔的一根手指上有一个V形疤痕。罗西奥的表哥是一个年轻人，长相与案发当晚被出租车司机发现的SUV司机很相似。他住的房子是8号。在罗西奥尸体附近发现的垃圾袋上就画着这个数字。几乎没有什么证据来支持克雷斯佩西奥警官这一充满争议的理论。由于缺乏规范的程序和科学方法，该理论随后被驳回。一些执法人员认为，克雷斯佩西奥警官公布调查结果是因为他想博取15分钟的名气。
But news of the dossier did prompt Dolores Vazquez to make her first public statement in months. On September 20, she held a press conference in front of 100 journalists and 18 television cameras. She stated, I didn't kill Rocio. I've been arrested without proof. I've been taken to prison and trial without proof. The fingerprints are not mine, and I'm just asking, not for me, but for Rocio, for the investigation to reopen and to let whoever has to fall, fall. Despite her pleas, there were very few developments in the case over the next year. It was accepted that Dolores would be facing court again, with her retrial scheduled for August 2003. Then, just days before Dolores was due back in court, Sonja Carabantas was attacked. Despite the similarities between the Vanenkov and Carabantas cases, Dolores Vazquez couldn't have possibly committed both murders.
但档案的消息确实促使多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯发表了几个月来的首次公开声明。9月20日，她在100名记者和18台摄像机前举行了一场新闻发布会。她声明道：“我没有杀罗西奥。我在没有任何证据的情况下被捕。我在没有任何证据的情况下被送进监狱并接受审判。指纹不是我的，我在此请求，不是为了我自己，而是为了罗西奥，重新展开调查，让该承担责任的人受到惩罚。”尽管她百般恳求，但在接下来的一年里，案件进展甚微。人们已经接受多洛雷斯将再次出庭的事实，重审定于2003年8月进行。然而，就在多洛雷斯即将重返法庭的前几天，索尼娅·卡拉班塔斯遭到袭击。尽管维宁科夫案和卡拉班塔斯案有诸多相似之处，但多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯绝不可能犯下这两起谋杀案。
When Sonja was abducted, Dolores was under strict surveillance at home, awaiting her day in court. Upon learning that the two murders were connected via a male smoker, the Supreme Court postponed Dolores' retrial so that the investigation could pan out. Investigators examined other unsolved cases involving missing and murdered girls to see if they were dealing with a serial killer. The brutality of Rocio and Sonja's murders made them certain that whoever was responsible had attacked before. There were likely other women out there who'd encountered him. Not long after Sonja Carabantas went missing, a woman named Cecilia Pantoja met her ex-husband outside her home when he came to collect their daughter. As Cecilia and her boyfriend stood chatting with her ex, whose name was Tony King, they noticed that one of his hands was badly swollen and covered with cuts. Cecilia's boyfriend asked about the injury, and King said something about how he'd been speeding in his car and ended up injuring himself.
当索尼娅被绑架时，多洛雷斯正处于家中的严密监视之下，等待着她出庭的日子。在得知两起谋杀案通过一名吸烟的男性嫌疑人联系在一起后，最高法院推迟了多洛雷斯的重审，以便调查能够深入展开。调查人员审查了其他涉及失踪和遇害女孩的未破案件，以确定他们是否在面对一名连环杀手。罗西奥和索尼娅遇害手段的残忍程度让他们确信，凶手以前一定作过案。可能还有其他女性曾遭遇过他的毒手。就在索尼娅·卡拉班塔斯失踪不久后，一个名叫塞西莉亚·潘托亚的女人在自家门外遇到了她的前夫，当时前夫来接他们的女儿。正当塞西莉亚和她的男友与前夫（名叫托尼·金）站在一起闲聊时，他们注意到他的手肿得厉害，上面布满了伤口。塞西莉亚的男友询问了伤势，金随口编了个理由，说自己开车超速结果弄伤了自己。
The story sounded far-fetched. Neither Cecilia nor her boyfriend believed it. It wasn't the first time Cecilia felt uncomfortable about her ex-husband. A few years earlier, when Cecilia was still married to King, a friend told her she'd seen him on a British television program about wanted criminals. Terrified by this revelation, Cecilia called Scotland Yard to find out more. They informed her that King had committed a series of robberies. Believing King's crimes weren't violent, Cecilia let the matter rest. On the night of Saturday, October 9, 1999, King arrived home close to midnight. He was behaving strangely. He ran straight to the bathroom and locked the door. Cecilia went to check on him. As he emerged, she noticed he had some minor injuries and was carrying a pile of blood-stained clothes.
这个说法听起来很离谱。塞西莉亚和她的男友都不相信。这并不是塞西莉亚第一次对前夫感到不对劲。几年前，当塞西莉亚和金还维持着婚姻关系时，一个朋友告诉她，曾在英国一档关于通缉犯的电视节目中看到过他。塞西莉亚被这个消息吓坏了，她打电话给苏格兰场了解更多情况。他们告知她金曾犯下一系列抢劫案。由于认为金的罪行不涉及暴力，塞西莉亚便没有再追究此事。1999年10月9日星期六的深夜，金回到家中。他的行为十分反常。他径直跑向浴室并反锁了房门。塞西莉亚前去查看他的情况。当他走出来时，她注意到他受了一些轻伤，手里还拿着一堆沾有血迹的衣服。
King insisted on washing the clothing himself. Cecilia didn't inquire further. A few days later, she saw on the news how a 19-year-old named Rocio Vanenkov had gone missing. The same night King returned home with blood-stained clothing. Cecilia couldn't shake a sinking feeling that her husband was involved. When Sonja Carabentas disappeared, that same feeling returned. The Civil Guard had established a tip-line to assist them in identifying suspects in the murder of Sonja Carabentas. One day, a call came through offering them a promising lead. The police sprung into action. On the night of September 17, 2003, officers drove to the apartment complex where Tony King lived with his new partner and her three children.
金坚持自己清洗这些衣服。塞西莉亚没有再多问。几天后，她在新闻上看到一个名叫罗西奥·维宁科夫的19岁女孩失踪的消息。就在同一天晚上，金带着血衣回到了家。塞西莉亚始终有一种挥之不去的沉重预感，觉得她的丈夫牵涉其中。当索尼娅·卡拉班塔斯失踪时，那种熟悉的感觉又回来了。国民警卫队设立了一条热线，以协助他们确定索尼娅·卡拉班塔斯谋杀案的嫌疑人。一天，一个电话打了进来，为他们提供了一条有希望的线索。警察立即采取了行动。2003年9月17日晚，警官们开车来到托尼·金与新伴侣及她三个孩子居住的公寓大楼。
But they didn't knock on his door. Instead, they waited and watched, just in case King decided to flee. But nothing indicated that he was aware his ex-wife had reported him to police. The officers made note of a small white Mazda parked in King's garage. It was consistent with a vehicle scene driving around Sonja's neighborhood on the night of her murder. It also had a broken tail light that perfectly matched the piece they'd found near her home. The following morning, when King walked out of the building, officers pounced. He was immediately handcuffed. He looked stumped as he was placed under arrest. During interrogations, investigators pieced together more information about their suspect.
但他们没有敲门。相反，他们在那里守候观察，以防金选择潜逃。但没有任何迹象表明他知道前妻已经向警方举报了他。警官们注意到停在金的车库里有一辆白色小马自达。这与在索尼娅遇害当晚在她家附近行驶的车辆特征相符。它还有一个破损的尾灯，与他们在索尼娅家附近找到的那块碎片完美吻合。第二天早上，当金从楼里走出来时，警官们一拥而上。他当场被戴上手铐。在被捕时，他显得一脸茫然。在审讯过程中，调查人员拼凑出了更多关于这位嫌疑人的信息。
King was a 38-year-old British man who'd moved to Spain six years prior. He'd worked odd jobs and was currently employed as a waiter in an English pub. King was informed that he was being investigated for the murder of Sonja Carabentas. He was told that his DNA was being analyzed at that very moment. Within a matter of hours, they would know whether or not he was the person who had attacked her. King paused for several seconds, seemingly processing the situation. Then he broke down and offered to share his side of the story. A month earlier, on Wednesday, August 13, Tony King visited a local pub at 3pm and stayed until midnight.
金是一名38岁的英国男子，六年前移居西班牙。他做过零工，目前在一家英国酒吧当服务员。金被告知他正因涉嫌谋杀索尼娅·卡拉班塔斯而接受调查。警方告诉他，他的DNA此刻正在接受分析。只需短短几个小时，他们就能知道他是否是袭击索尼娅的人。金沉默了几秒钟，似乎在消化这个情况。接着他崩溃了，并主动提出讲讲他那一边的故事。一个月前的8月13日星期三，托尼·金在下午3点去了一家当地酒吧，一直待到午夜。
His girlfriend joined him for a couple of hours and the couple visited a few more bars. When they returned home, King took a sleeping pill and went to bed, but he couldn't fall asleep. After tossing and turning, he got up. He told his girlfriend he was going out to buy some tobacco. King claimed he couldn't remember much of what happened next. Muddled and hazy from the combination of alcohol and medication, he got into his car and drove to the Coyin Fair. As he was driving back home, he accidentally ran over a teenage girl who he later realized was Sonja Carabentas. Scared and unsure of what to do, he placed her body in the boot of his car. He headed northwest in the direction of Monda, 10km away.
他的女友陪了他几个小时，随后两人又去了几家酒吧。当他们回到家时，金吃了一片安眠药便上床睡觉了，但他却怎么也睡不着。在床上翻来覆去之后，他起了床。他告诉女友自己要出去买烟。金声称自己记不清接下来发生了什么。由于酒精和药物的作用，他感到头脑昏沉、迷迷糊糊，于是他坐上车，开车前往科因集市。在开车回家的路上，他意外撞倒了一个少女，后来他意识到那正是索尼娅·卡拉班塔斯。由于害怕且不知所措，他把她的尸体放进了汽车后备箱。他朝着西北方向的蒙达驶去，那里距离此地10公里。
At one point, he pulled over and moved Sonja into the backseat with the intention of abusing what he believed to be her dead body. Sonja regained consciousness and began to fight him off. That was when King strangled her. He dragged her body into the heavily wooded area where she was later found. He then grabbed rocks at random and used them to conceal her body. Investigators didn't believe King's actions were thoughtless. The rock placed on Sonja's head had been a different size and shape to the others, as though it was intended as a marker that someone could spot from a distance. They suspected King had planned to return to Sonja's body again. King also admitted to killing Rocio Vanenkov.
途中，他把车停下，将索尼娅移到了后座，企图对当时被他认为已经死亡的尸体进行猥亵。索尼娅恢复了意识并开始反抗。就在那时，金勒死了她。他把她的尸体拖到树木茂密的区域，也就是后来发现尸体的地方。接着，他随意抓起一些石头，用它们来掩盖尸体。调查人员并不认为金的行为是不经大脑的。压在索尼娅头上的那块石头在大小和形状上与其他石头不同，仿佛它是作为一个可以从远处被发现的标记。他们怀疑金原本打算再次回到索尼娅的尸体藏匿处。金还承认杀害了罗西奥·维宁科夫。
He claimed he'd spent the evening of Saturday, October 9, 1999 at a house belonging to his friend, Robert Graham. The pair smoked joints and drank together. As it was time to go, he left in a friend's Ford Fiesta that he'd borrowed after having an accident in his own car. As King drove along a quiet road, he spotted Rocio walking. He was immediately taken with her and started fantasizing about touching her. King followed Rocio as she turned down an even quieter path and overtook her in his car. Then he got out and showed her a knife, thinking it would intimidate her into submission. But instead of cowering in fear, Rocio launched herself at him, attempting to fight him off.
他声称自己于1999年10月9日星期六的晚上在朋友罗伯特·格雷厄姆的家里度过。两人一起抽大麻烟并饮酒。到了该离开的时候，他开着朋友的一辆福特嘉年华离开，这辆车是他在自己的车发生事故后借来的。当金沿着一条安静的道路开车时，他看到了正在走路的罗西奥。他立刻被她吸引，并开始幻想触摸她。当罗西奥拐入一条更安静的小路时，金一路尾随，并在车里超过了她。随后他下了车，向她展示了一把刀，以为这能恐吓她并使其屈服。但罗西奥非但没有吓得缩成一团，反而向他扑过来，试图进行反抗。
In response, King cut her throat, then stabbed her abdomen in a frenzy so she would stop screaming. King tossed the knife aside and fled the scene, only to return a few hours later to move Rocio's body. He molested her corpse before dumping her at the tennis court. It took King 10 hours to confess to these crimes. He also admitted to attacking at least three other women in the area. His motivation was sexual. He struggled to perform with his partners and preferred to masturbate while assaulting the bodies of unconscious or deceased young women. Investigators didn't buy King's confessions, which were riddled with false information.
作为回应，金割断了她的喉咙，随后疯狂地刺向她的腹部，以让她闭嘴。金将刀随手一扔便逃离了现场，几个小时后却又折返回去移动罗西奥的尸体。他在抛尸网球场前猥亵了罗西奥的尸体。金花了10个小时才供认这些罪行。他还承认袭击了当地至少另外三名女性。他的动机是性方面的。他在与伴侣进行性行为时感到力不从心，更喜欢在袭击失去意识或已经死亡的年轻女性尸体时通过手淫获得快感。调查人员并不相信金的供词，里面充斥着虚假信息。
Although he said he ran Sonja down as she was walking in front of him, his car was only damaged at the rear. The injuries he described inflicting on Rocio didn't match her wounds. But detectives had no doubt that King was involved in both crimes. King was held in custody while investigators gathered evidence. His clothing was bagged for testing. His white Mazda was transferred to the station and the Spanish Home Office asked their UK counterparts for details on King's prior convictions. But before they received the information, the British press beat them to the punch, turning the case on its head for the second time. On September 23, the Daily Mail and The Sun, two of the UK's most popular tabloids, revealed that Tony King's birth name was Tony Bromwich and he was originally from Holloway, North London.
尽管他说他在索尼娅走在他前方时将她撞倒，但他的车只有后部受损。他描述对罗西奥施加的伤害与她身上的伤口并不相符。但侦探们毫不怀疑金参与了这两起犯罪。金被拘留期间，调查人员搜集了证据。他的衣服被装进袋子用于检测。他的白色马自达被转移到了警察局，西班牙内政部要求英国同行提供关于金先前定罪的详细信息。但还没等他们收到这些信息，英国媒体就抢先一步，第二次将案件闹得天翻地覆。9月23日，《每日邮报》和《太阳报》这两家英国最受欢迎的小报披露，托尼·金的原名叫托尼·布罗姆维奇，他最初来自伦敦北部霍洛韦。
Back in his country of birth, he was a notorious criminal who'd been dubbed the Holloway Strangler. At the age of 19, King started prowling the streets of North London on Monday and Wednesday evenings, the nights when he didn't see his fiance. He was looking for women who were walking alone. When he spotted one, he crept up on her from behind, then wrapped a cord around her neck and squeezed. Once the woman was rendered unconscious, King assaulted her. He did this to at least five different women, until he was caught red-handed. He was taken to trial, where the judge described him as possessing a jekyll and Hyde personality. By day, he behaved as a responsible citizen and a loving partner.
回到他的出生国后，他是一个声名狼藉的罪犯，被称为“霍洛韦扼杀者”。在19岁时，金开始在周一和周三晚上（也就是他不去看未婚妻的那些夜晚）在伦敦北部街头徘徊。他在寻找独自走路的女性。当发现目标时，他从后面悄悄溜过去，然后将一根绳子缠在她的脖子上并收紧。一旦女性失去意识，金就会对其实施袭击。他用这种方法对至少五名不同的女性下手，直到他被当场抓获。他被送上法庭，法官形容他具有杰基尔和海德式的双重人格。白天，他表现得像一个负责任的公民和慈爱的伴侣。
But two nights every week, he acted out his violent fantasies. King was sentenced to 10 years in juvenile detention, which was later reduced to five for good behaviour. A few weeks after his release, King attempted to rob a woman at gunpoint. He was sent back to prison, then freed again in 1995. Soon after this, he changed his name and moved to Spain. The British tabloids shared that UK authorities had forwarded King's criminal files to the Spanish police soon after he arrived in the country. They'd cautioned their Spanish counterparts to keep a close eye on King, as he posed a major threat to women. In addition to these revelations, King's ex-wife Cecilia publicly revealed that she had, in fact, reported her husband to police after he came home covered in blood on the night Rocío Vanencoff vanished.
但每周有两个晚上，他会将自己暴力的幻想付诸行动。金被判处10年少管所监禁，后因表现良好减刑至5年。出狱几周后，金试图持枪抢劫一名女性。他再次被送回监狱，随后于1995年获释。此后不久，他改了名字并移居西班牙。英国小报透露，英国当局在金抵达该国后不久就将他的犯罪档案转交给了西班牙警方。他们曾警告西班牙同行密切关注金，因为他对女性构成了重大威胁。除了这些爆料，金的前妻塞西莉亚也公开透露，在罗西奥·维宁科夫失踪当晚，金浑身是血地回到家后，她确实曾向警方举报过自己的丈夫。
However, the officer she'd spoken to never wrote a report or followed up with her. This made her reluctant to speak out when she became suspicious again in 2003, so a friend of hers called the tip line to report Cecilia's concerns instead. Spain's law enforcement and government found themselves under a barrage of criticism. How had they missed so many red flags about Tony King? Perhaps if they'd kept an eye on him from the beginning, or at least investigated him after Rocío disappeared, then some of his crimes might have been prevented. The Home Office Minister claimed Scotland Yard was partially to blame because they marked King's file as low priority. The National Police received hundreds of reports on international convicts every year. It was impossible to chase everyone up unless they were flagged as important. In the aftermath of his confessions, Tony King penned two letters. Both were published in the papers. They were addressed to Rocío and Sonja's mothers. To Alicia, he apologized for not owning up to his crime earlier and for causing a rift in her relationship with Dolores Vazquez.
然而，她与之交谈的警官从未写过报告，也没有跟进调查。这使得她在2003年再次产生怀疑时很不愿开口说话，于是她的一个朋友转而拨打热线电话举报了塞西莉亚的担忧。西班牙的执法部门和政府发现自己遭到了猛烈的抨击。他们怎么会漏掉关于托尼·金的这么多危险信号呢？也许如果他们从一开始就盯着他，或者至少在罗西奥失踪后对进行调查，他的一些犯罪行为本可以被阻止。内政部部长声称苏格兰场负有部分责任，因为他们将金的档案标记为低优先级。国家警察每年都会收到数百份关于国际罪犯的报告。除非被标记为重要人物，否则不可能逐一追查。在交代了罪行后，托尼·金写了两封信。两封信都在报纸上发表了。它们是写给罗西奥和索尼娅的母亲的。他向阿丽西娅道歉，为自己没有早点承认罪行以及导致她与多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯关系破裂而道歉。
He apologized to Sonja's mother for running over her daughter and said he hoped the trial wouldn't be painful for her. Neither mother was interested in hearing from King and publicly rejected his apologies. Almost immediately, King responded by saying he'd written the letters under false pretenses. A journalist with a law degree had posed as his newly appointed attorney and told King that apologies meant a lot in Spanish culture. If he wrote letters saying sorry to the victim's parents, then he might secure a lighter sentence. As well as coaxing the letters out of him, the journalist obtained an exclusive to our interview. After King's real lawyer met with his client, he told the media King had a difficult upbringing that made him prone to confessing things he hadn't done. To back up this assertion, the attorney pointed to discrepancies between King's version of events and the evidence in the Vanenkov and Karabentes cases.
他向索尼娅的母亲道歉，因为自己撞了她的女儿，并表示希望这场审判不会给她带来痛苦。两位母亲对收到金的信件都不感兴趣，并公开拒绝了他的道歉。几乎立刻，金回应说他在虚假的情形下写了这些信。一名拥有法律学位的记者伪装成他新委派的律师，告诉金在西班牙文化中道歉意义重大。如果他写信向受害者的父母道歉，也许就能获得较轻的刑罚。除了诱使他说出这些信件的内容外，这名记者还获得了独家采访权。在金真正的律师与他的客户会面后，他告诉媒体，金有一个艰难的成长经历，这使他容易承认自己没有做过的事情。为了支持这一断言，律师指出了金的事件版本与瓦年科夫案和卡拉班塔斯案证据之间的矛盾之处。
He also made a startling claim that was related to King's friend, Robert Graham. King and Graham were close, hanging out on a daily basis. King said he'd been with Graham on the night of Rocio's murder. Detectives apprehended Graham two days after King's arrest and kept him in custody for 72 hours before releasing him. In those three days, Graham was interviewed extensively but claimed not to remember anything about that night four years earlier. He was insistent, however, that he wasn't with King at the time of the murder. Subsequently, investigators asked Graham to undergo hypnosis to see if there were any relevant memories locked in his subconscious. Graham agreed.
他还提出了一个与金的朋友罗伯特·格雷厄姆有关的惊人说法。金和格雷厄姆关系密切，每天都在一起厮混。金说在罗西奥遇害的那晚他曾和格雷厄姆在一起。侦探们在金被捕两天后逮捕了格雷厄姆，并将他拘留了72 hours才将其释放。在那三天里，格雷厄姆接受了广泛的盘问，但声称不记得四年前那一晚的任何事情。然而，他坚称自己在谋杀发生时没有和金在一起。随后，调查人员要求格雷厄姆接受催眠，以查看他的潜意识中是否锁定了任何相关的记忆。格雷厄姆同意了。
The session ended with an alarming statement. While hypnotized, Graham claimed that Dolores Vasquez had collaborated with King to commit the crime. As it turned out, King had previously worked as a waiter at a hotel where Dolores was employed in a managerial position. King's lawyer dismissed this claim, suggesting detectives concocted the entire thing to push their own narrative. Their investigation had been problematic from the start and here was a convenient way to cover up the holes in their case. He remarked that no matter how the investigators were choosing to proceed, the truth would come out. Graham's statement and the hotel link between Tony King and Dolores Vasquez saw Dolores dragged back into the case again. Just as she was getting momentum in her quest for innocence, rumors began circulating that she had indeed committed Roccio's murder with King's help.
催眠结束时留下了一个令人震惊的陈述。在被催眠期间，格雷厄姆声称多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯曾与金合作实施了这起犯罪。事实证明，金此前曾在一家酒店当过服务员，而多洛雷斯在那里的管理岗位上工作。金的律师驳斥了这一说法，暗示侦探们捏造了这一切，以推动他们自己的叙事。他们的调查从一开始就存在问题，而这正是掩盖其案件漏洞的便捷方法。他评论说，无论调查人员选择如何进行，真相终将大白。格雷厄姆的陈述以及托尼·金与多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯之间的酒店纽带，使得多洛雷斯再次被卷入此案。正当她在寻求清白的道路上取得进展时，有传言开始流传，称她确实在金的帮助下犯下了罗西奥的谋杀案。
In an effort to silence this gossip once and for all, Dolores held a press conference to state that she did not know King and had never met him before. He started working at the hotel long after she'd moved on to another job. She concluded by saying, I can't do this anymore. I didn't kill Roccio and anything I say is twisted and turned against me. What does this country want from me? Investigators were torn. On the one hand, they kept looking for a connection between Dolores and King. On the other, they discussed eliminating Dolores completely from the case. Some people were pressuring them to issue a public apology.
为了彻底平息这些流言蜚语，多洛雷斯举行了一场新闻发布会，声明她不认识金，也从未见过他。他在她转到另一份工作很久之后才开始在那家酒店工作。她最后说道：“我受够了。我没有杀罗西奥，我说的一切都被扭曲并用来针对我。这个国家到底想从我这里得到什么？”调查人员陷入了两难境地。一方面，他们继续寻找多洛雷斯和金之间的联系。另一方面，他们讨论了将多洛雷斯从该案中彻底排除的可能性。有些人向他们施压，要求他们发表公开道歉。
Detectives asked Robert Graham to provide a new deposition, but he fled to London after his previous interviews and said he was unable to return to Spain due to economic problems. Then, at a court hearing on November 13, King stunned everyone by providing a brand new version of what happened the night of Roccio's murder. He'd been hanging out at Graham's home when Graham received a phone call. After hanging up, he asked King to drive with him to meet someone. King agreed. They drove to a quiet road where Roccio was standing on her own, waiting. Graham got out of the car while King stayed inside. From where he was watching, it looked as though Graham and Roccio were lovers.
侦探们要求罗伯特·格雷厄姆提供一份新的证词，但他在此前的审讯后逃往伦敦，并称由于经济问题无法返回西班牙。接着，在11月13日的法庭听证会上，金抛出了一个关于罗西奥谋杀案当晚发生经过的全新版本，震惊了所有人。当时他一直在格雷厄姆家里厮混，这时格雷厄姆接到了一个电话。挂断电话后，他让金开车带他去见某个人。金同意了。他们开车来到一条安静的路上，罗西奥正独自站在那里等待。格雷厄姆下了车，而金则留在车里。从他的视角看过去，格雷厄姆和罗西奥看起来就像是一对恋人。
After a few minutes, Graham became violent and stabbed Roccio repeatedly. Afterwards, he asked King to help him move her. They hid her behind the tennis court where she was eventually found. In this version, King only participated by moving the body. He'd felt pressured to help Graham who had a domineering personality and dodgy associates. Now, the Spanish government was determined to do everything in their power to bring Graham back into the country. Graham finally agreed to return after negotiating via his lawyer. One month later, he appeared before a Spanish judge.
几分钟后，格雷厄姆变得情绪激动并多次刺伤罗西奥。事后，他让金帮他转移尸体。他们把她藏在网球场后面，她最终就是在那儿被发现的。在这个版本中，金只是通过移动尸体参与了此事。他感到压力很大，不得不帮助格雷厄姆，因为格雷厄姆性格专横且有着不三不四的同伙。现在，西班牙政府决心尽一切努力将格雷厄姆带回国内。格雷厄姆通过律师谈判后，终于同意返回。一个月后，他出庭接受西班牙法官的审讯。
He denied having anything to do with Roccio's murder. He said the only thing he could recall from that night was what he'd revealed under hypnosis. He maintained that Dolores Vasquez was behind the crime as the master puppeteer. With so many varying statements and stories changing along the way, nobody knew where the truth lay anymore. Roccio's mother was deeply distressed by the constantly shifting claims. The last thing she wanted was for her daughter's murder to end up unsolved. Over the next year and eight months, Tony King attempted to derail the pending trial against him by hiring new legal counsel and changing his story yet again. He began to point the finger at both Robert Graham and Dolores Vasquez.
他否认自己与罗西奥的谋杀案有任何关系。他说自己对那个晚上唯一能记起来的事情，就是他在催眠状态下透露的内容。他坚持认为多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯才是这起犯罪背后的幕后黑手。随着这么多的证词不断变化、故事一路发生改变，已经没人知道真相究竟在何方。罗西奥的母亲对不断变化的供词深感痛苦。她最不希望看到的就是她女儿的谋杀案最终成为悬案。在接下来的一年零八个月里，托尼·金试图通过聘请新的法律顾问并再次改变他的说法，来破坏针对他的未决审判。他开始将矛头指向罗伯特·格雷厄姆和多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯两人。
He also attempted to blame Graham for another well-known case involving a third missing girl. Yet, the irrefutable evidence was that King's DNA was found at both crime scenes. Further analysis revealed that one of his hairs was left inside a plastic bag dumped by Roccio's body. By February 2005, Dolores Vasquez and Robert Graham were completely eliminated as suspects in Roccio's case. Tony King would be subject to two consecutive trials. The first one would be for the murder of Sonia Carabentes. The trial for Sonia's murder began in September 2005. King was dragged into court kicking and screaming.
他还试图将涉及第三名失踪女孩的另一个知名案件归咎于格雷厄姆。然而，无可辩驳的证据是，在两个案发现场都找到了金的DNA。进一步的分析显示，他的一根头发留在了罗西奥尸体旁丢弃的一个塑料袋里。到2005年2月，多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯和罗伯特·格雷厄姆被彻底排除在罗西奥案件的嫌疑人名单之外。托尼·金将面临两场连续的审判。第一场审判将针对谋杀索尼娅·卡拉班特斯。索尼娅谋杀案的审判于2005年9月开始。金被拖入法庭，一路上大喊大叫、又踢又闹。
As he was escorted inside, he stared at the television cameras and shouted at the ceiling, I'm innocent and haven't done anything. As well as changing his claims about Roccio's murder, he was now telling a new version of events with regards to Sonia. In this story, he'd gotten out of his car after accidentally hitting her. As he knelt over her body to check if she was alright, someone bashed his head from behind several times, knocking him unconscious. When he came to, he was in the back seat of a car next to Sonia. His friend Robert Graham was driving. Graham eventually pulled over and dumped Sonia's body, covering it with rocks. As they drove home, King threw Sonia's jeans out the window in the hopes it would lead her to be found.
当他被押送进去时，他盯着摄像机，对着天花板大喊：“我是无辜的，我什么都没做。”除了改变关于罗西奥谋杀案的供词外，他现在针对索尼娅一事又编造了一个新的事件版本。在这个故事中，他在意外撞到索尼娅后下了车。当他跪在她的尸体旁检查她是否安好时，有人从后面猛击他的头部好几次，把他打得失去意识。当他醒来时，他已经在索尼娅旁边的一辆车的后座上了。他的朋友罗伯特·格雷厄姆正在开车。格雷厄姆最终把车停下并抛弃了索尼娅的尸体，用石头将其盖住。在他们开车回家的路上，金把索尼娅的牛仔裤扔出窗外，希望这能让人找到她。
King claimed Dolores Vazquez had orchestrated the entire thing, supposedly paying for the crime to make herself appear innocent in the Roccio-Vanenkov case. King was a helpless pawn who found himself in the wrong place at the wrong time. The prosecution called on lots of witnesses to refute King's claims. His girlfriend revealed he'd come home that night with blood splattered all over him and an injured hand. The second he saw her, he mumbled, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm bad. He told her he'd gone to buy tobacco and got in a car accident. There were no signs of any head injuries, as he was now alleging. One of her friends had also come forward to say she'd seen King at the Coyin Fair that night, loitering near the youth tent.
金声称多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯策划了整起事件，据称是为了花钱买凶，好让自己在罗西奥-瓦年科夫案中显得无辜。金只是一个无助的棋子，阴差阳错地在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。控方传唤了大量证人来反驳金的供词。他的女友透露，那天晚上他回家时，身上溅满了血迹，手上还有伤。他一见到她就喃喃自语道：“对不起，对不起，我变坏了。”他告诉她自己是去买烟，结果遭遇了车祸。根本没有他现在所声称的任何头部受伤的迹象。她的一位朋友也出面向警方作证，称当晚在科因集市上看到过金在青年帐篷附近闲逛。
The same place Sonia had gone with her friends. A woman who owned a car wash said King had taken his white Mazda there and specifically asked her to clean the car's interior, but not the boot. While completing the job, she noticed red stains on the floor and seats. King claimed these were from ink. There was also a foul stench. The prosecution pointed to Sonia's injuries, telling the court she was killed as the result of an attack. Several witnesses had seen blood stains right outside Sonia's house, but none had seen paint spots or tire tracks that would indicate a car accident. Moreover, the location and direction of the blood, which was in between two parked cars and not on the road, indicated Sonia had most likely been struck in a surprise assault. Their theory was that King hid behind a tree waiting for Sonia as she walked home.
索尼娅和她的朋友们也去过同一个地方。一名经营洗车行的女性说，金曾将他的白色马自达开到那里，并明确要求她清洗汽车内部，但不要洗后备箱。在完成清洗工作时，她注意到地板和座位上有红色的污渍。金声称这些是墨水造成的。车里还有一股恶臭。控方指出索尼娅身上的伤势，向法庭陈述她是在遭到袭击后被杀害的。几位证人看到索尼娅家门外有血迹，但没有人看到任何表明车祸的油漆点或轮胎印。此外，血迹的位置和方向（位于两辆停放的汽车之间，而不是在路上）表明索尼娅极有可能是遭到了一次突袭。他们的推测是，金躲在树后，当索尼娅步行回家时守株待兔。
As she approached, he jumped out and hit her in the head, knocking her unconscious. Then he placed her in the boot of his car. He drove 12 kilometers to Monda looking for an isolated area and stopped in a clearing located in an industrial field. He moved Sonia from the boot into the back seat and sexually assaulted her. She came to and fought back, scratching him with her fingernails. King beat her, causing internal and external injuries that were so serious they alone could have caused her death. But King didn't stop there. He grabbed Sonia's t-shirt and used it to strangle her. Afterwards, he carried her body outside and hid it under some heavy rocks.
当她走近时，他跳出来击打她的头部，将她打得失去意识。然后他把她放进汽车后备箱。他开车12公里来到蒙达寻找一个偏僻的地方，并停在工业区的一片空地上。他把索尼娅从后备箱移到后座，并对其实施了性侵。索尼娅恢复了意识并进行反抗，用指甲抓伤了他。金殴打她，造成了严重得足以致命的体内和体外损伤。但金并没有就此罢休。他抓起索尼娅的T恤，勒住了她的脖子。事后，他将她的尸体抱到外面，藏在几块重石之下。
In summing up, prosecutors reminded the court that King initially admitted to the crime without any coercion. He also confessed to three other attacks that they weren't even investigating him for. He'd acknowledged that he saw women as prey and enjoyed attacking them so he could later masturbate to the memory. Tony King was found to guilty and sentenced to 23 years for murder, 8 years for sexual aggression and 5 years for illegal detention. In total, he was to serve 36 years in prison. He also had to pay €300,000 in compensation to Sonia's family. King was dragged out of court behaving in exactly the same way as he had on his way in. He kicked and screamed that he was innocent and was being used as a pawn in somebody else's plan.
在总结陈词中，公诉人提醒法庭，金最初是在没有任何胁迫的情况下承认了罪行的。他还承认了另外三起甚至不在调查范围内的袭击。他曾承认自己将女性视为猎物，并且喜欢袭击她们，以便日后通过回忆来自慰。托尼·金被判有罪，因谋杀罪被判处23年监禁，因性侵犯罪被判处8年监禁，因非法拘禁罪被判处5年监禁。他总共需要在监狱服刑36年。他还必须向索尼娅的家人支付30万欧元的赔偿金。金被拖出法庭时的行为与他进来时如出一辙。他又踢又叫，坚称自己是无辜的，只是别人计划中的一颗棋子。
But his trials were far from over. He still had Rocio's murder to answer for. When King's trial for the murder of Rocio Vanenkov began in November 2006, he arrived in court repeating what had now become his signature carry-on. Photographers and television crews shot him as he screamed at the top of his lungs that he was innocent. In his opening statement, King's attorney told the court, Nobody stabs another person 9 times to commit a sexual aggression. If somebody stabs another person 9 times, it has to be powered by hate and cruelty. The defense was arguing that this attack had been personally motivated and Dolores Vasquez had to be the killer. When King took the stand, he gave what became his fourth version of the events of October 9, 1999.
但他的审判远远没有结束。他还有罗西奥的谋杀案需要交代。当金因谋杀罗西奥·维宁科夫而受审时，时间来到了2006年11月，他到达法庭时重复着已经成为他标志性的闹剧。摄影师和电视摄制组拍下了他声嘶力竭地尖叫自己是无辜的画面。在开案陈词中，金的律师对法庭说：“没有人会为了性侵而把另一个人捅9刀。如果有人把另一个人捅9刀，那必然是由仇恨和残忍驱使的。”辩方辩称，这次袭击有着强烈的个人动机，多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯必定是真凶。当金走上证人席时，他给出了关于1999年10月9日事件的第四个版本。
He had gone to Robert Graham's house and the two drank and did drugs for a few hours before Graham made a strange request. He wanted to try hypnotizing someone and asked if King would volunteer. King agreed. After Graham hypnotized him, things became confusing and strange. Three individuals arrived at Graham's house, two men, one of whom was known to King and Dolores Vasquez. One of the men soon left. From then on, King couldn't recall much else. He remembered waking up in the front passenger seat of a British car with its steering wheel on the right side
他去了罗伯特·格raham的家，两人喝了酒并吸了几小时毒，随后格raham提出了一个奇怪的要求。他想尝试催化某人，并问金是否愿意当志愿者。金同意了。在格raham催化他之后，事情变得混乱而诡异。三个人来到了格raham的家，其中两个是男人，一人金认识，另一人是多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯。其中一个男人很快离开了。从那时起，金记不清太多其他事了。他记得自己在一辆英国汽车的前排乘客座上醒来，方向盘在右侧，
and driving up to a village near La Cala de Míaz. They stopped at an isolated area. King turned around to look behind him and saw Rócio Vanencoff in the back seat with Dolores Vasquez. Dolores began stabbing Rócio repeatedly while laughing maniacally. King saw that Dolores was holding Rócio's underpants in one hand. After this incident, he had no further involvement in the case. He hadn't even been present when Rócio's body was moved. When Rócio's mother, Alicia, was asked for her thoughts outside the courtroom,
车子开到了拉卡拉德米亚斯附近的一个村庄。他们在偏僻的地方停了下来。金转过身向后看，看到罗西奥·瓦宁科夫和多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯坐在后座上。多洛雷斯一边狂笑，一边开始疯狂地刺杀罗西奥。金看到多洛雷斯一只手里拿着罗西奥的内裤。这起事件之后，他再也没有参与这个案件。罗西奥的尸体被转移时，他甚至不在场。当法庭外有人问及罗西奥的母亲阿利西亚的看法时，
she said she believed King's new story completely. Rócio had been such a careful young woman that the only way Alicia could make sense of her murder was if she'd been lured in by someone she knew. Rócio's family couldn't shake the belief they'd held for years, that Dolores Vasquez was behind at all. They agreed King was involved, but investigators had previously told them the murderer had to be a woman. Rócio's aunt even testified that she thought Dolores was behind the murder, saying she'd seen Dolores hit or scream at Rócio on three separate occasions. She believed Dolores had truly hated Rócio.
她说她完全相信金的新说法。罗西奥是一个如此谨慎的年轻女子，阿利西亚能理解她遇害的唯一方式，就是她被自己认识的人诱骗了。罗西奥的家人无法摆脱多年来的信念，即多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯才是这一切的幕后黑手。他们承认金参与其中，但调查人员此前曾告诉他们，凶手必须是一个女人。罗西奥的阿姨甚至作证说，她认为多洛雷斯是谋杀案的幕后主使，并表示她曾三次看到多洛雷斯殴打或大声斥责罗西奥。她相信多洛雷斯是真的恨罗西奥。
A psychiatrist who treated King in prison said that while King was on remand, he'd penned a personal manuscript about the murders of Sonja and Rócio. While he always admitted involvement in Sonja's death, he never took the same responsibility for Rócio. Instead, he implicated Robert Graham and Dolores Vasquez. King had told his psychiatrist that the only reason he ever confessed was because he felt threatened by police. He was scared that if he didn't, something bad would happen to his daughter. In summing up, the prosecutor dismissed all of the conspiracy theories by listing the bare-bones facts of the case. When King had initially confessed to Rócio's murder, the knife he described using perfectly matched her injuries.
一名在监狱里治疗金的精神病医生表示，金在候审期间写了一份关于索尼娅和罗西奥谋杀案的个人手稿。虽然他一直承认自己参与了索尼娅的死，但他从未对罗西奥承担同样的责任。相反，他将罗西奥的死归咎于罗伯特·格raham和多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯。金曾对精神病医生说，他认罪的唯一原因是他感到受到了警察的威胁。他害怕如果自己不认罪，他的女儿会遭遇不测。在总结陈词中，检察官通过列举案件的赤裸裸的事实，驳斥了所有的阴谋论。当金最初承认谋杀罗西奥时，他所描述使用的凶器与她的伤情完全吻合。
His DNA was found at the site where she was attacked, as well as in one of the plastic bags by her body. King was well acquainted with the area where Rócio had been dumped. And finally, investigators had been unable to find any evidence to verify King's later version of events. After the prosecutor closed his case, there was a cry from the public gallery. Rócio's mother, Alicia, unsure of what to believe any longer, screamed loudly, Who killed my daughter? Without missing a beat, King shouted back. Dolores Vasquez, she paid. Just as Alicia tried to ask how much Dolores had paid, court guards escorted her outside to calm down.
他的DNA在罗西奥被袭击的现场以及她尸体旁的一个塑料袋里被发现。金对罗西奥被抛尸的地区非常熟悉。最后，调查人员无法找到任何证据来证实金后来的说法。在检察官结束案情陈述后，旁听席上传出一声哭喊。罗西奥的母亲阿利西亚不再知道该相信什么，她大声尖叫道：“谁杀了我女儿？”金毫不犹豫地大声回喊：“是多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯，她付了钱。”正当阿利西亚试图追问多洛雷斯付了多少钱时，法庭警卫将她护送出去以平复情绪。
King was given a final opportunity to speak before the jury left to deliberate. Addressing to court, King gave a fifth version of how Rócio had been killed. In this story, two unknown individuals in two different cars cornered Rócio in the middle of the road, hit her in the head, then threw her down a hill. King said this explained why the clearing where the attack occurred had a large puddle of blood, but no footprints nearby. After several hours, King was found guilty on all counts, though the jury believed he'd had help from one or two people. He was sentenced to 19 years for murder and ordered to pay 210,000 euros to Rócio's mother and 42,000 euros to each of her siblings. Outside of court, Alicia told the media that she was thrilled with the result, but now the rest of the guilty parties needed to pay.
在陪审团休庭退席商议之前，金获得了最后一次发言的机会。在法庭上，金给出了关于罗西奥是如何被杀害的第五种说法。在这个故事中，两个身份不明的人驾驶两辆不同的车在路中间把罗西奥逼入绝境，击打她的头部，然后将她扔下山坡。金说，这解释了为什么袭击发生的开阔地上有一大滩血迹，但附近却没有脚印。几个小时后，金被裁定所有罪名成立，不过陪审团认为他得到了一个或两个人的协助。他因谋杀罪被判处19年监禁，并被勒令向罗西奥的母亲赔偿21万欧元，向她的每个兄弟姐妹赔偿4.2万欧元。庭审结束后，阿利西亚对媒体表示，她对判决结果感到高兴，但现在其余的罪魁祸首也必须付出代价。
Alicia was determined that Dolores Vasquez and Robert Graham betrayed for her daughter's murder as well. Over the past few years, she'd experienced some disturbing incidents that she now pointed to as proof that some of her daughter's killers were still out there. It started in September 2005, when King's trial for the murder of Sonja Carabantas was about to begin. Someone left a plastic bag outside Alicia's home. Inside was a pair of bloody underpants, which she believed belonged to Rócio. Then, just as King's trial for her daughter's murder was starting, a second plastic bag was deposited at Alicia's house. It contained hair and 400 coins that were valued at roughly 348 euros. Alicia had no idea what they were supposed to signify, but she was convinced it was connected to her daughter's case.
阿利西亚坚信多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯和罗伯特·格raham也为她女儿的谋杀案背叛了正义。在过去的几年里，她经历了一些令人不安的事件，她现在指出这些事件证明了她女儿的一些凶手仍然在逍遥法外。这一切始于2005年9月，当时金因谋杀索尼娅·卡拉班塔斯而受审的案件即将开始。有人在阿利西亚家门外留下了一个塑料袋。里面有一条带血的内裤，她认为这属于罗西奥。接着，就在金因谋杀她女儿受审即将开始之际，第二个塑料袋被放在了阿利西亚的家里。里面有头发和400枚价值约348欧元的硬币。阿利西亚不知道这些东西代表什么，但她确信这与她女儿的案件有关。
She took both bags to her lawyer, arguing they should be entered as evidence against Graham and Dolores. Her request was denied. To this day, Alicia remained suspicious of Dolores Vasquez. Over the years, Tony King has sent her letters sharing even more stories about what supposedly happened to Rócio. Numerous TV hosts and journalists who've interviewed Alicia have put it to her that it was impossible for Dolores to be behind the crime. But she remains certain Dolores is responsible because she feels no other explanation makes sense. Tony King has also been convicted of an attempted rape that occurred in 2001. The survivor recognized him when she saw a news report about Sonja Carabantas's case.
她把两个袋子都交给了她的律师，辩称这些应该作为针对格raham和多洛雷斯的证据。她的请求被拒绝了。直到今天，阿利西亚仍然对多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯抱有怀疑。多年来，托尼·金给她寄了许多信，分享了更多关于罗西奥遭遇的虚构故事。采访过阿利西亚的众多电视主持人和记者都向她指出，多洛雷斯不可能幕后操纵这起犯罪。但她仍然确信多洛雷斯应负全责，因为她觉得没有其他解释说得通。托尼·金还被裁定犯有2001年发生的一起未遂强奸罪。幸存者在看到关于索尼娅·卡拉班塔斯案的新闻报道时认出了他。
King had attacked the woman as she was walking towards her car. Upon seeing his photograph, she immediately reported him to the police. He was subsequently sentenced to an additional seven years. King denied committing the crime, saying that if he'd wanted to rape the woman, it wouldn't have ended in an attempt. King and his friend Robert Graham were also looked into for another cold case. In August 2000, 18-year-old Maria Teresa Fernandez Martin vanished in Motril, 150km from La Cala de Mijas. King and Graham were reportedly seen in the area around the same time. When investigators were interrogating King, he made several references to Maria Teresa's disappearance and alluded to being involved.
金在那个女人走向她的汽车时袭击了她。一看到他的照片，她立刻向警方报案。随后他又被判处七年监禁。金否认自己犯罪，并称如果他想强奸那个女人，事情就不会以未遂告终。金和他的朋友罗伯特·格raham还因另一桩冷案受到调查。2000年8月，18岁的玛丽亚·特蕾莎·费尔南德斯·马丁在距离拉卡拉德米亚斯150公里的莫特里尔失踪。据报道，金和格raham在同一时期被发现在该地区活动。当调查人员审讯金时，他多次提到玛丽亚·特蕾莎的失踪，并暗示自己参与其中。
To this day, however, the case remains unsolved. In 2010, Tony King asked to be relocated to a British prison for the remainder of his sentence. His request was denied. He isn't scheduled to be released until 2059. After her conviction was quashed, Dolores Vazquez was left devastated by the impact the allegations had on her. She battled with depression and post-traumatic stress. In 2006, Dolores filed a formal complaint against Spain's Department of Justice, citing physical, psychological and emotional scars that would never go away. She was asking for 4 million euros in compensation.
然而直到今天，这起案件仍然悬而未决。2010年，托尼·金请求被转移到英国监狱服完剩下的刑期。他的请求被拒绝了。他预计要到2059年才能获释。在她的定罪被撤销后，多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯对这些指控对她造成的影响感到心碎欲绝。她与抑郁症和创伤后应激障碍进行了斗争。2006年，多洛雷斯对西班牙司法部正式提起诉讼，称这些指控留下了永远无法消除的身体、心理和情感创伤。她要求赔偿400万欧元。
Eventually, the department acknowledged that mistakes had been made during the initial investigation and trial, and offered Dolores 120,000 euros. They said this was a generous amount. Ordinarily, they offered a rate of 120 euros per day to compensate for an injustice, but they were giving Dolores 231 euros for every day she'd spent incarcerated. Through her lawyer, Dolores reminded the department of the amount she had been seeking. It took years for the issue to be resolved. Early in 2011, the Department of Justice reassessed Dolores Vazquez's case and determined she didn't deserve compensation at all. A new law that passed in 2010 decreed that because there had been a murder, compensation wasn't available, even if Dolores was innocent of the crime. Rocio Vanenkov's case had a significant impact on the Spanish legal system.
最终，司法部承认在最初的调查和审判中犯下了错误，并向多洛雷斯提供了12万欧元。他们表示这是一笔丰厚的金额。通常情况下，他们提供的赔偿标准是每因冤狱关押一天赔偿120欧元，但他们给多洛雷斯在狱中度过的每一天赔偿了231欧元。多洛雷斯通过她的律师提醒司法部她最初要求的金额。这个问题花了多年时间才得以解决。2011年初，司法部重新评估了多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯的案件，并认定她根本不配得到赔偿。2010年通过的一项新法律规定，由于发生过谋杀案，因此不提供赔偿，即使多洛雷斯是清白的。罗西奥·瓦宁科夫的案件对西班牙法律体系产生了重大影响。
It led to people questioning the role of jury trials, which were only introduced in Spain in 1995, four years before Rocio's murder. When jurors determined that Dolores Vazquez was guilty, they did so without citing any evidence they'd used to draw that conclusion. This troubled legal experts, as there was no physical evidence implicating Dolores. Some questioned whether citizens with no legal training or experience are suited to make a judgment on someone else's guilt or innocence. Jury trials are still prevalent in Spain, however lawyers and judges make frequent references to the conviction of Dolores Vazquez, cautioning juries that such a trial not be repeated. Dolores Vazquez tried moving to the UK to start a new life, but eventually returned to Spain. It's been suggested that prejudices about Dolores' sexuality contributed to the hostility against her. She was often portrayed by the media as a, quote, predatory lesbian, who relentlessly pursued Rocio's mother.
它引发了人们对陪审团审判角色的质疑，陪审团制度是1995年（罗西奥遇害四年前）才引入西班牙的。当陪审团裁定多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯有罪时，他们并没有引用任何支持这一结论的证据。这令法律专家感到困扰，因为没有任何物理证据将多洛雷斯牵连其中。一些人质疑没有法律培训或经验的普通公民是否适合对他人是否有罪做出判断。尽管陪审团审判在西班牙仍然普遍，但律师和法官经常提及对多洛雷斯的定罪，警告陪审团不要重蹈覆辙。多洛雷斯·巴斯克斯曾试图搬到英国开始新生活，但最终还是回到了西班牙。有人认为，对多洛雷斯性取向的偏见加剧了针对她的敌意。她经常被媒体描绘成一个“掠夺性的女同性恋”，对罗西奥的母亲穷追不舍。
In the years since her daughter's murder, Alicia has said that Dolores manipulated her into having a relationship, and has denied being bisexual. In 2013, Dolores made a rare public appearance. She was invited to speak in front of legal activists who were studying her case and the problem of what Spain had dubbed parallel trials. A parallel trial is when a case is essentially being tried by the media while also going through the courts. In such instances, what happens inside the courtroom is typically dictated by the narrative in the press. Dolores described how her life had changed since being implicated in Rocio's murder. She keeps a detailed journal noting everywhere she goes, just in case she gets taken in for questioning again. She drops down license plate numbers of cars she thinks might be stalking her.
在她女儿遇害后的几年里，阿利西亚曾表示多洛雷斯操纵她发展了一段关系，并否认自己是双性恋。2013年，多洛雷斯罕见地公开露面。她应邀在研究她的案件以及西班牙所谓的“影子审判”问题的法律活动人士面前发言。影子审判是指案件在通过法庭审理的同时，本质上也受到了媒体的审判。在这种情况下，法庭内部发生的事情通常由媒体的叙事所左右。多洛雷斯描述了自从被牵连进罗西奥谋杀案以来，她的生活发生了怎样的变化。她保留了一份详细的日记，记录她去的每一个地方，以防她再次被带去接受讯问。她记下那些她认为可能在跟踪她的汽车的车牌号。
It's hard for her to go about her normal life without strangers stopping and staring at her. To this day, some people in Spain still believe Dolores to be guilty. She explained that more important than any monetary compensation is an apology from the government and a public declaration that she is innocent. . There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对她来说，过上正常生活很难，免不了会有陌生人驻足盯着她看。直到今天，西班牙仍有一些人认为多洛雷斯有罪。她解释说，比任何金钱赔偿更重要的是政府的道歉以及公开声明她是无辜的。这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。